TO THE HELLO PARKS WATER PARKS
AND WILDLIFE -- GENDER -- TO
TUESDAY APRIL THIRTIETH TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN I'M ASK -- AS
A MEMBER QUIRK IT'LL COME FOR
WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND THAT TAKE UP THE FIRST ISSUE
.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
UP FIRST ARM IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS IT SAYS CONSIDERATIONS.
YOU OFFER MAY WISH TO CONSIDER
ENCOURAGING CONGRESS TO RE
AUTHORIZE AN AD CALIFORNIA. TO
THE NUTRIA EDUCATE RATIFICATION
AND CONTROL ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
THREE AND IF IT'S OKAY WITH THE
CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS.
I'D LIKE TO DO THAT -- IN THE
SENATE [inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M A ARE A REQUEST TO CONGRESS
AT CALIFORNIA. TO PROVISIONS THE
NEUTRAL CONTROL NUTRIA CONTROL
ACT.
AND RE AUTHORIZED AN
APPROPRIATION TO CALIFORNIA.
TO RATHER KATE NUTRIA -- WITH AN
AMOUNT OF FOUR MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR.
OUR LARGE QUANTIC RODENTS THAT
HAVE RECENTLY ESTABLISHED AN
INVASIVE PRESENCE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THE RAPID POPULATION GROWTH.
GROWTH RAPIDLY STRIPS WETLANDS
OF VEGETATION.
TRANSFORMING BURDEN MARTIAN TO
OPEN WATER BEYOND HABITAT
DESTRUCTION NUTRI HABITUALLY BAR
AND TO LEVEES AND RIVER BANKS
THREATENING THEIR STABILITY.
AJ ARE EIGHT SEEKS TO BRING THE
SAME PROGRAM TO SUCCESSFULLY
ERADICATED NUTRIA IN THE
CHESAPEAKE BAY CALIFORNIA.
TESTIFYING WITH ME TODAY IS
VALERIE COOK FLETCHER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
INCREASED ANDERSON FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES ACCRA.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY.
IF YOU MENTION MY NAME IS
VALERIE COOK FLETCHER I'M A
SENIOR ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENTISTS
SUPERVISOR WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE'S INVASIVE
SPECIES PROGRAM AND SERVING AS
THE NUTRIA REVOCATION INCIDENT
COMMANDER WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY
ABOUT THE CURRENT STATUS OF THE
NUTRIENT VISION IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S IMPACTS.
AND THE RESPONSE EFFORTS WITH IN
CALIFORNIA.
AS HE MENTIONED NUTRI WERE
DISCOVERED IN MARCH OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN A PREGNANT
FEMALE WITHIN MERCED COUNTY OVER
THE NEXT YEAR AN ADDITIONAL
THIRTY ANIMALS WERE DISCOVERED
FROM SAN JOAQUIN.
STANISLAUS MERCED FRESNO
MARIPOSA INTO ON THE COUNTIES --
NUTRIA RODENTS THEY REPRODUCE
EARLY AND OFTEN AND AS HE
MENTIONED -- THEY'RE ABLE TO
RAPIDLY EXPAND BOTH OUR
POPULATION SIZE AND THEIR
GEOGRAPHIC DISTRIBUTION WE
ESTIMATE THAT WITH THE SOURCE
POPULATION OF FIFTY ANIMALS
WITHOUT INTERVENING CONTROL
EFFORTS. FOR FIVE YEARS TIME
THAT POPULATION COULD BECOME.
OVER TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND ANIMALS.
THESE ANIMALS LIVE IN COLONIES
TYPICALLY OF A DOMINANT MALE AND
MULTIPLE REPRODUCING FEMALES.
THAT TO DRIVE OUT MATURING
JUVENILES WHICH CAN DISPERSE AS
FAR AS FIFTY MILES SO THAT IS A
RAPID EXPANSION BOTH IN
POPULATION SIZE AND GEOGRAPHIC
DISTRIBUTION.
THE FEEDING AND BURROWING
ACTIVITIES OF NUTRIA BECAUSE
DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS WITH IN
CALIFORNIA -- INCLUDING LOSS OF
DESIRABLE VEGETATION DEGRADATION
OF VALUABLE HABITAT FOR
WATERFOWL ANOTHER WELL AND I
LOOK AT SPECIES.
EXACERBATIONS OF INVASIVE PLANT
POPULATIONS AND ALSO LOSS OF OF
SOIL ORGANIC MATTER THE HOLES
TOGETHER ARE WETLAND SOILS.
FURTHER -- AND WE DO HAVE A
REPRESENTATIVE TO SPEAK TO
IMPACTS INFRASTRUCTURE BUT
THEY'RE BORROWING ACTIVITY ALSO
CAUSES SEVERE EROSION AND
SEDIMENTATION WHICH IMPACTS --
SELMON IT'S WITHIN THE DELTA
TRIBUTARY THAT RELY ON THOSE
SYSTEMS FOR SPAWNING.
FOLLOWING THE DISCOVERY OF
NUTRIA IN CALIFORNIA THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
INSTITUTED AN INCIDENT COMMAND
SYSTEM.
RE DIRECTING STAFF RESOURCES AND
FUNDING TO PLAN COORDINATE AND
INITIATE A RATIFICATION EFFORTS
WITHIN THE STATE.
WELL THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE WORKS INTERNALLY TO
SURVEY FOR NUTRIA PRESENTS AND
TRAP KNOWN INFESTATIONS
ALONGSIDE OUR CONTRACTOR
WILDLIFE SERVICES.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE IS ALSO CONDUCTING --
DELIMITATION SURVEYS AROUND THE
PERIMETER OF THE INFESTATION TO
HELP US DETERMINE THE FULL
GEOGRAPHIC EXTENT OF THE
INFESTATION.
TODAY THE DEPARTMENT HAS
OBTAINED OVER TWENTY NEARLY
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED LANDOWNER
PERMITS TO BE ABLE TO ACCESS
PRIVATE PROPERTIES FOR SURVEYS
ENTRAPPING WE'VE ASSESSED OVER
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
ACRES FOR NUTRI PRESENTS ARE
HABITAT SUITABILITY.
WE'VE CONFIRM TO THEIR THEIR
PRESENCE IN ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FOUR LOCATIONS AND HAVE
NOW REMOVED FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SEVEN NUTRIA FROM THE
STATE.
IN SUMMER TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
WITH THE ANTICIPATED FUNDING
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS
WELL AS AN IMPENDING DELTA
CONSERVANCY GRANT WE ANTICIPATE
TRANSITIONING FROM THE INCIDENT
COMMAND SYSTEM INTO A FORMAL
DEDICATED DEPARTMENT PROGRAM. TO
IMPLEMENT A RATIFICATION OVER
THE LONG TERM.
THAT PROGRAM WILL SEE EXPANSION
OF FIELD OPERATIONS INTEGRATION
OF ADDITIONAL PROJECT COMPONENTS
INCLUDING JUDAS NUTRIA AND SENT
DETECTION DOGS.
AND WILL CONTINUE OVER THE LONG
TERM UNTIL SUCCESSFUL --
EDUCATION IS ACHIEVED.
LASTLY I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT -- EARLY RAPID RESPONSE
EFFORTS HAVE BEEN PRIMARILY
FUNDED THROUGH RE DIRECTED
DEPARTMENT FUNDING AND SHORT
TERM GRANTS FROM THE WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION BOARD THE
SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN DELTA
CONSERVANCY IN THE US FISH AND
WILDLIFE SERVICE.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS CHRIS
ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES AKEL REPRESENTS MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES WHICH TOGETHER
ACCOUNT 490% OF THE WATER
DELIVERED IN CALIFORNIA.
OUR MEMBERS RELY ON AN EXTENSIVE
SYSTEM OF CANALS DIKES AND DAMS
TO MEET THE AGRICULTURAL
MUNICIPAL AND INDUSTRIAL NEEDS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
HOWEVER NUTRIA THREATEN THE
INTEGRITY OF EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING THE SAT
IN THE SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN
DELTA A CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S WATER DELIVERY
SYSTEM.
THE DELTA THROUGH THE STATE
WATER PROJECT'S SUPPLIES WATER
TO TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS AND IRRIGATES THREE
MILLION ACRES OF FARMLAND. THREE
SEVEN HUNDRED MILES OF CANALS
TUNNELS AND PIPELINES.
ADDITIONALLY THE CENTRAL VALLEY
PROJECT PROVIDES AN ANNUAL
AVERAGE OF FIVE MILLION ACRE
FEET OF WATER FOR AGRICULTURAL
PURPOSES.
NUTRI ARE ALREADY WIDESPREAD IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND I'VE BEEN
DETECTED IN THE SOUTHERN DELTA.
THE EXISTENCE IN SPREADING
NUTRIENT CALIFORNIA CAN DAMAGE
CAN FAN CONVEYANCE FACILITIES
AND OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE
ADDITIONALLY THEY ARE KNOWN TO
CARRY HEALTH HAZARDS WHICH COULD
CONTAMINATE WATER SUPPLIES.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY BERMAN SO THAT I
CAN [inaudible] FOR EDUARDO
GARCIA [inaudible]
GALLAGHER BIGELOW [inaudible]
CHOI [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible] TO I'VE
[inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN CRISTINA GARCIA.
GLORIA KALRA LEVINE BLANCA RUBIO
[inaudible]
SALAS WOOD.
THE MOVE THE BILL OKAY.
THE MOTION WE HAVE A SECOND THAT
BOTHERS FOR IN ROUGHLY PLEASE
PROCEED YOU DO HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND OKAY THANK CAL BE BRIEF --
NUTRI COULD UNDOUBTEDLY RESULT
IN SUBSTANTIAL ECOLOGICAL AND
ECONOMIC IMPACTS INCLUDING LOTS
OF WATER SUPPLY AND FLOOD
CONTROL CAPACITY FORTUNATELY
WE'VE SEEN THAT IN MARYLAND THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN
SUCCESSFULLY RADICALLY NUTRIA.
IS NECESSARY TO BRING THIS
COLLABORATIVE MULTI PRONGED
EFFORT TO CALIFORNIA AJ ARE
EIGHT IS AN IMPORTANT STEP IN
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA'S WATER
DELIVERY SYSTEM.
WATER SUPPLY AND FRAGILE ECOLOGY
OF THE DELTA OCKLEY PARKWAY
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING NO WELL KRAMER'S OF
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT I
JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT OF THE
WORK IN MARYLAND TO RADIC KATE
NUTRIA WAS NOT EASY BUT IT WAS
MUCH EASIER THAN IT WILL BE IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE IT WAS
ESSENTIALLY A SINGLE LANDOWNER
THAT THEY HAD. TO WORK WITH IN
CALIFORNIA WORDS MUCH MORE
COMPLEX BECAUSE WE HAVE MANY
MORE LAND OWNERS AND SO THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING -- REQUESTED
IN AG ARE EIGHT IT WILL BE
IMPERATIVE TO BEING SIX TO A
SUCCESSFUL REPLICATION PROGRAM
THANK YOU.
THOSE WISHING -- TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING BY THE TIME SOME OF
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING BETH A LOSS ON
BEHALF OF THE INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE OPEN.
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
WE WILL BRING BACK ANY QUESTIONS
PLEASE SOME MEMBER.
SO HOW DO THEY GET FROM STATE TO
STATE AND DO NOT LEAVE THAT TO
FISHING GAME THAT.
WE BELIEVE THIS WAS AN
INTENTIONAL REINTRODUCTION.
THE THE REASONS BEHIND THAT
WE'RE NOT YET SHORE BUT AND WE
MAY NEVER BE SURE BUT I SUSPECT
IT WAS EITHER INTRODUCTION. FOR
RECREATIONAL HUNTING OR
POTENTIALLY FOR THE BELIEF THAT
THEY WOULD CONTROL -- INVASIVE
PLANT POPULATIONS IN IN AREAS
WITH SEVERE INFESTATIONS OF
WATER HYACINTH FOR EXAMPLE.
SOUTHERN SOUTH AMERICA.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS [inaudible]
PLEASE.
CLEAR FOR YOU SAID A RE
INTRODUCTION.
HOW TO DEFINE THAT FOR SO WE
BETTER UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY HERE
PREVIOUSLY THESE ANIMALS ARE
NATIVE TO SOUTHERN SOUTH AMERICA
THEY WERE INTRODUCED TO NORTH
AMERICA FOR THE FOR TRADE IN THE
EARLY NINETEEN HUNDREDS?
THEY WERE FORMED IN CALIFORNIA
IN THE THIRTIES AND FORTIES BUT
ONCE THE FOR MARKET COLLAPSED.
ON THESE ANIMALS THERE WERE
ESCAPES ANIMALS WERE RELEASED WE
HAD FERAL POPULATIONS IN THE
FIFTIES AND SIXTIES AND THEY
WERE THEN SUBSEQUENTLY DECLARED
A RADIC AIDED IN THE SEVENTIES
WITH NO DETECTIONS BUT FROM THE
SEVENTIES.
UNTIL.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN SO THEY
WERE BROUGHT HERE FOR A FOR
MARKET.
AND WE HAVE LEGISLATION TO
PROTECT [inaudible] FOR
CREATURES.
THAT PUTS DOT ORIGIN.
I UNDERSTAND THAT NUTRIA HAS
BEEN.
ELIMINATED FROM THAT BUT IT WAS
PART OF A ACTUAL FOR TRADE
MARKET SYSTEM.
DO WE POTENTIALLY HAVE EVEN THE
WERE.
SOURCING THAT AS AN INDIVIDUAL.
ONE OFF SO IT IT WON'T BE
PROTECTED.
HOW CAN WE HAD HOW DO WE LOOK AT
THAT MISTER CHAIR?
IT'S A REAL INTRIGUING SCENARIO
BECAUSE IT WAS HERE FOR A SAID
PURPOSE SO LIKE MANY OF THE
CREATURES THAT ARE BEING TALKED
ABOUT PROTECTING SEVEN NUTRIA SO
NUTRI ARE NOT PROTECTED LIKE
ANIMALS SET FOR BEAR SUCH AS
AUTRES THESE ARE CLASSIFIED AS A
NON GAME MAMMAL.
AND ALSO -- YOU'RE ABLE TO HUNT
THEM AS RODENTS BUT ALSO THESE
ARE RESTRICTED SPECIES IN
CALIFORNIA SO IT IS ILLEGAL TO
IMPORT TRANSPORTER POSSESS THEM
WITHIN THE STATE BECAUSE OF
THEIR DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS.
I APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE THAT'S
THE SAME SCENARIO YOU KNOW I'VE
CARE TO BUILD FOR WILD PIGS AND
IT'S THE SAME EXACT.
SITUATION THEY WERE IMPORTED
HERE THEY WERE PLANTED HERE FOR
GAME FOR OTHER PURPOSES AND IF
TURN INTO.
A TREMENDOUS NUISANCE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IN FACT CAUSING THE
SAME PROBLEMS THAT YOU OUTLINED
IN YOUR REPORT TO THIS COMMITTEE.
WITH IMPACTS TO THE WILD LANDS
INTO THE TO THE LEVEES AND SUCH
SO.
HOPEFULLY WE CAN -- SOMEDAY WORK
BEGAN ON THAT MR CHAIRMAN.
MAYBE SEE SOME SUCCESS ON THAT
BILL GETTING SIGNED.
THANK YOU RAISE SOME GOOD POINTS
SHAPE THE WITNESSES RESPONSES.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
DR PLEASE YA OBVIOUSLY FOR THE
PROBLEM I HAVE NO PROBLEM OPPOSE
SUPPORTING IT UP BUT I'M CURIOUS --
HE READ A CANING NOW WHAT I'M
METHODOLOGIES IDEA YOU IS IN A
SELF POLICING OR TRAPPING ALONG
WITH THE DATE WE ARE STRICTLY
TRAPPING AND DISPATCHING WE ARE
NOT USING POISONS AND HAVE NO
INTENTIONS OF USING POISONS.
OKAY SO THAT THE METHODOLOGY --
HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN IN OTHER
STATES ARE LIKE LOUISIANA --
LOUISIANA UNFORTUNATELY HAS HAS
GIVEN UP HOPE.
ON A RATIFICATION OF THEIR
TRYING TO MAINTAIN THE
POPULATION BUT IN THE CHESAPEAKE
THEY RELY STRICTLY ON ON
TRAPPING EFFORTS AND WE HAVE HAD
GOOD SUCCESS WITH OUR LIVE
TRAPPING EFFORTS WE ARE A GOAL
OF THIS EFFORT IS TO ALSO
MINIMIZE IMPACT TO NON TARGET
SPECIES.
SO WE ARE PRIMARILY LIVE
TRAPPING SO THAT WE CAN RELEASE
IN A NON TARGET CAPTURES THE
TRAPPING METHODOLOGY WE WE CAN
100% SUCCEED.
WE BELIEVE SO.
OKAY THANK YOU.
YES SIR YEAH I JUST A BRIEF
QUESTION ON WHAT WHAT PRAISE ON
NUTRIA IF THERE ARE OTHER
ANIMALS THAT TO HELP WITH THE
THAT THE POPULATION CONTROL.
WITHIN THEIR NATIVE EXCUSE ME
WITHIN THEIR NATIVE RANGE THEY
ARE PREYED UPON BY -- LARGE CAP
SUCH AS JAGUARS AN AWFUL IT'S
ALSO BY CAME IN AND THEIR HUNTED
AS A FOOD SOURCE.
IN LOUISIANA THEIR PREYED UPON
BY ALLIGATOR SWITCHER NATIVE
SPECIES -- VENOMOUS AQUATIC
SNAKES AND ALSO HUNTED VIA THE
THE BOUNTY PROGRAM WHICH IS --
AN INCENTIVE JUST MAINTENANCE
CONTROL MECHANISM WITHIN THE
CHESAPEAKE BAY THEY ARE PREYED
UPON -- BY.
LARGE BIRDS OF PREY SO EAGLES
HAVE BEEN DOCUMENTED -- AND
THEIR POPULATION AND
REPRODUCTION IS INHABITED BY THE
SEVERE WINTERS WHICH CAUSE
MORTALITY IN JUVENILES AND
ADULTS.
THESE ARE ALL FACTORS THAT WE DO
NOT HAVE CONTRIBUTING TO
MORTALITY WITH IN CALIFORNIA --
THE CLOSEST.
SIMILAR ANIMALS THAT WE MIGHT
EXPERIENCE PROTECTION FROM WOULD
BE MOUNTAIN LIONS BOBCATS
COYOTES -- WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT THOSE WILL PLACE THE A
SUBSTANTIAL ROLE IN PREDATION IN
IN TAMPING DOWN THE POPULATION
AND WE ALSO DO NOT HAVE THOSE
SEVERE WINTERS.
THAT PLAY SUCH A ROLE IN THE
CHESAPEAKE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
OKAY THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK US. TO THE AUTHOR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES.
IN THE SEVENTIES WE DID HAVE A
PROFESSIONAL -- FOR FOR TRAPPING.
HAPPY NEW FOR ANIMALS WE NO
LONGER HAVE THAT.
ARE SO THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE'RE GOING TO HAVE -- TO
SPEND RESOURCES ON IT IF WE
STILL HAD A PROFESSIONAL.
OFFER TRAPPING -- INDUSTRY IT
WOULD BE DIFFERENT BUT WE DON'T.
SO I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY
SOME A DOLLY SECOND BY.
THIS IS RUBIO -- MEDITECH TAPES
CULTURAL.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AT
WATER GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA I GALLAGHER -- IN
IT LIKE.
THANK YOU JAMES.
GALLAGHER I'D.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU -- CHIU AYE DALLY.
DALY AYE FRIEDMAN.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA I GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA.
LEVINE.
LEVINE I BLANCA RUBIO.
SUMMER MATHIS COME FORWARD
[inaudible]
SECOND TERM.
AND A FINAL ITEM. FOR THE AGENDA
[inaudible]
WITH.
GOOD MORNING WELCOME
[inaudible]
MORNING [inaudible]
PLEASE.
MORNING MR CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I AM PROUD TO PRESENT ACA. THREE
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION TODAY.
IT SHOULD BE NO SURPRISE TO
ANYONE ESPECIALLY THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE THAT WATER IS A
HUGE PRIORITY.
IN OUR STATE. FOR DECADES WE
HAVE SEEN BONTA AFTER BOND BILL
AFTER BILL.
ALL WITH THE INTENTION OF
ADDRESSING OR PERPETUAL WATER
CRISIS IN THE SHORT RUN.
HOWEVER.
WE ARE LEFT WITH THE UNDERLYING
PROBLEM SURROUNDING WATER IN
CALIFORNIA.
A SEVERE AN UNACCEPTABLE LACK OF
SECURE AND RECURRING FUNDING.
FOR OUR VITAL WATER PROJECTS
[inaudible]
EACH YEAR.
SHE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PILOT.
TO A DISASTROUS AND COSTLY EMMA.
WE SEE ENVIRONMENTAL PROJECTS
LEFT UNDER FUNDED.
OR BANDED POTENTIALLY RESULTING
AND PERMANENT DAMAGES TO OUR
ECOSYSTEM.
WE ALSO SEE FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES WITH NO WATER WHAT
SO EVER.
WITHIN MANY OF OUR DISTRICTS.
THERE ARE SEVERAL AREAS.
IN WHICH THE WATER IS HAZARDOUS.
AN UNSAFE FOR HUMAN CONSUMPTION.
WITHIN MY DISTRICT THERE ARE
AREAS WHERE THERE'S NO WATER.
AT ALL.
YOU'VE ALL HEARD ME TALK.
ABOUT THE DISASTER ANY SUPPORT
OF BILL MANY TIMES BEFORE.
SO I'LL BE BRIEF IT'S KNOWN AS
THE CITY WITHOUT WATER.
EACH DAY.
FAMILIES HAD TO DRIVE DOWN TO
THE LOCAL CHURCH. TO TAKE
SHOWERS.
THAT MOBILE UNITS.
IF THEY GOT THERE TOO LATE.
THE WATER SUPPLY WAS GONE THEY
HAD TO FORGO SHOWERING.
DOINGDISHES BRUSHING THEIR
TEETH FOR THAT ENTIRE DAY
[inaudible]
PUT SIMPLY.
I HAD BETTER CONDITIONS WHY WAS
DEPLOYED.
IN IRAQ DURING THE WAR.
OUR PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING FROM
THIRD WORLD WATER CONDITIONS IN
OUR STATE.
OUR STATE WHICH BOASTS BEING THE
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY.
IN THE WORLD.
SADLY.
I KNOW THAT THIS DISASTER IS NOT
UNIQUE TO MY DISTRICT ALONE
[inaudible]
MISTER CHAIR.
YOUR CONTENTION ONCE EXPERIENCE
AN ALMOST IDENTICAL SITUATION
EACH DAY [inaudible]
I APPRECIATE.
ALL OF YOUR SUPPORT AND
LEADERSHIP IN THIS ISSUE.
AND FOR RECOGNIZING THE MERIT IN
VALUE THAT A CA THREE BRINGS TO
CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
YOUR CONSTITUENTS NEED THIS
MEASURE.
IN RECENT YEARS.
WE'VE SEEN A STAGGERING NUMBER
OF WATER BONDS.
ON OUR BALLOT.
THESE EFFORTS HAVE ADDED
[inaudible] TO OUR EIGHTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR OUTSTANDING
GENERAL FUND SUPPORTED BOND DEBT.
THERE HAVE BEEN EIGHT BONDS
APPROVED BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN IN
NOVEMBER.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN HOWEVER.
VOTERS REJECTED PROPOSITION.
THREE AN EIGHT POINT.
NINE BILLION DOLLAR WATER BOND.
SIGNALING A FUNDAMENTAL DESIRE
BY THE VOTERS TO SHIFT AWAY FROM
BOX.
ACCORDING TO THE PP I SEE.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND STATE BONTA
HELPS.
PHIL FUNDING GAPS.
WHAT BONDS ARE NOT A RELIABLE
LONG TERM SOURCE?
AND THEY GENERALLY DON'T COVER
OPERATING AND MAINTENANCE COSTS.
LOOKING BEYOND BONDS TO FILL
GAPS SHOULD BE A TOP PRIORITY.
WE CANNOT KEEP MOVING FORWARD.
WITH PEACE NO WATER FUNDING.
IT IS SIMPLY TOO IMPORTANT. TO
NOT LOOK AT WATER FUNDING ON THE
LARGE SCALE.
WE MUST SHIFT.
TOWARDS A MORE APPROPRIATE AND
PERMANENT.
PAY AS YOU GO FUNDING SYSTEM.
ACCORDING TO THE LA ILL.
WE FIND THAT BOND FUNDING WOULD
NOT BE APPROPRIATE BECAUSE BONDS
PROVIDE A ONE TIME FUNDING
SOURCE.
AND SHOULD NOT BE RELIED ON AS
AN ONGOING FUND SOURCE.
MOREOVER GENERAL OBLIGATION
BONDS ARE REPAID FROM THE
GENERAL FUND.
WITH INTEREST AND THEREFORE
WOULD BECAUSE THIS APPROACH TO
BE SOMEWHAT MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
DIRECT APPROPRIATIONS FROM THE
GENERAL.
FUND.
AS SUCH.
NOT ONLY WITH THE SHIFT SAVE ON
INTEREST PAYMENTS FROM GENERAL
OBLIGATION BONDS.
WE CAN EVEN BEGIN TO ADDRESS OUR
OUTSTANDING DEBTS.
THIS IS WHY ADONAI ALONG WITH
MANY COLLEAGUES HAVE AUTHORED A
CA.
THREE THIS MEASURE WHAT ANNUALLY
SET ASIDE 2%.
OF THE GENERAL FUND FOR THE
PURPOSES OF FUNDING ANY AND ALL
WATER PROJECTS [inaudible]
FOREVER THIS MEASURE WOULD
ALLOCATE 5%.
OF THE AVAILABLE FUNDS TO PAIN
DOWN PROP ONE WATER BOND DEBT.
THEN ADDRESSING SUBSCRIBE
ESSENTIAL SUBSEQUENT WATER BOND
DEBTS.
WE DECIDED TO TAKE A HOLISTIC
APPROACH.
WHEN DISCUSSING WATER FUNDING?
PRIORITIES AS EACH PART OF OUR
STATE IS FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT
NEEDS.
SUCH NEEDS.
ARE CONTINUALLY EXACERBATED.
BY A PERPETUAL AND WORSENING
DROUGHTS.
AND VICE VERSA.
OUR DISASTROUS FLOODS.
THESE DROUGHT HIGHLIGHT THE FACT.
THAT OUR WETLAND ECOSYSTEMS ARE
ON THE VERGE OF COLLAPSE AND
WITH WILL EVENTUALLY FADE AWAY.
WITHOUT PRO ACTIVE STEPS.
FURTHER WE CAN LOOK AT THE
OROVILLE DAM CRISIS OF TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND THE
FLOODING THAT ENSUED.
AS FURTHER PROOF THAT OUR SYSTEM
IS CRUMBLING.
AND IS IN DIRE NEED [inaudible]
OF REPAIR.
WITHOUT THE PROACTIVE APPROACH
FOUND AN ACA THREE CALIFORNIA'S
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE.
INCLUDING OUR NATURAL.
ENVIRONMENT FULLY CO SYSTEMS
WILL ULTIMATELY FAIL
[inaudible]
THIS FAILURE.
WHAT CATASTROPHICALLY JEOPARDIZE
PUBLIC HEALTH?
THE ENVIRONMENT AND OUR ECONOMIC
STABILITY.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS A PERMANENT FIX.
TO OUR CONTINUED SEVERE
FINANCIAL SHORTAGES AND WATER
FUNDING.
SHORTAGES THAT HAVE RESULTED.
IN THE DOUBLE PLAY A VITAL WATER
PROJECTS [inaudible]
AC.
THREE WILL PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
FRAMEWORK TO ENSURE THAT FUTURE
GENERATIONS WILL.
NEVER HAVE TO DEAL WITH THESE
ANNUAL CRISIS [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE MUST UPHOLD THE PROMISE WE
MADE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THE RIGHT TO SAFE CLEAN
AFFORDABLE.
AND ACCESSIBLE WATER ADEQUATE
FOR HUMAN CONSUMPTION COOKING
AND SANITARY PURPOSES.
PLEASE JOIN ME AND MY NUMEROUS
JOINT AUTHORS.
AND CO AUTHORS AND SUPPORTING
THIS BIPARTISAN EFFORT.
SHOULD ANY OF YOU WISH. TO JOIN
ON THIS MEASURE NOW ASK YOU FOR
YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS MORNING
MR TERM -- EMOTIONS SECOND
PLEASE TAKE A MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE PAUL
GUNS ALL THIS HERE TODAY
REPRESENT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WATER ASSOCIATION.
SINGLE VALUE WATER ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTS ABOUTSIXTY WATER
SUPPLIERS THAT SERVES ABOUT TWO
MILLION -- CUSTOMERS AND LA
COUNTY.
OVER THE PAST THIRTY YEARS THAT
WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH THE
NATION'S LARGEST DRINKING WATER
SUPERFUND SITE WE'VE LOCALLY
BEEN TRYING TO TAKE MEASURES.
THAT LEVERAGE LOCAL DOLLARS
FEDERAL FUNDING STATE BOND
FUNDING AND REALLY WE SEE THIS
AS THE STATE'S DEDICATION TO
WATER QUALITY PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT ARE
CRITICAL AND NEEDED.
THROUGH EVERYONE'S DISTRICTS SO
WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOR HIS FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS COME MORNING
DAVID WOLF THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF A CA THREE AND
ANOTHER SPENT A MOTION A SECOND
SO I'LL BE BRIEF -- 2% OF A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS WHICH IS
THE CURRENT GENERAL FUND BUDGET
IS TWO AND A HALF BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WOULD PROVIDE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER FOR A MILLION
CENTRAL VALLEY RESIDENTS
CURRENTLY WITHOUT ACCESS TO
CLEAN WATER.
AND WHAT A FIX THE OROVILLE DAM
AND THEY'RE STILL WOULD HAVE
BEEN MONEY LEFT OVER FOR OTHER
PROJECTS I THINK THIS IS A GOOD
BAIL -- YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE HAVE
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET WITH A SEVENTEEN
BILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
SURPLUS AT PRESENT -- I WOULD
ALSO JUST SAY THIS THE CURRENT
DEBT SERVICE RATIO IN THE
GENERAL FUND.
OF FOR BONDS IS ABOUT 5% 25% OF
THE CURRENT GENERAL FUND GOES TO
NOTHING MORE OR LESS THAN PAYING
OFF FIND AT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
PROP THREE THE WATER BOND LAST
NOVEMBER.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR OF
ONGOING GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURES OVER THIRTY TO
FORTY YEARS TO PAY OFF THAT DEBT --
AND THAT'S THAT'S A BIG DEBT
LOAD THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY HE HAD PROP
THREE PASSED IT WOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN THE ONLY WATER BOND ON
ABOUT WE HAVE PLENTY OF
OUTSTANDING DEBT -- SIR TO GET A
PERMANENT RELIABLE FUNDING
SOURCE THAT DOESN'T RELY ON DAT
YEAR OVER YEAR TO FUND THIS --
WE THINK IT'S COMPLETELY
APPROPRIATE WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
DENNIS I'LL BE ON THEIR BEHALF
OF THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MARIAN WARMER DOWN RURAL
COUNTIES WE SUPPORT. SEVENTY
MORAL CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
MUTUAL WATER COMPANIES THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND
ASK YOUR SUPPORT.
MIKE FLIES ON BEHALF OF FRONT
WATER AUTHORITY APPRECIATE THE
FOCUS ON INFRASTRUCTURE AND
FUNDING FOR WATER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION IMAGINE.
OKAY I'LL BRING IT BACK TO DíAS
SAID QUESTIONS DOCTOR WHAT.
YEAH.
FIRST OFF THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD -- I DO HAVE SOME I
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS -- FIRST OF
ALL WHY DID YOU WHERE DID YOU
HOW DID YOU ARRIVE ON 2%
[inaudible]
SO.
MR WAS THIS IS SOMETHING NOW
ACTUALLY ME IN THE CHAIR BEEN
WORKING ON FOR A FEW YEARS --
WHEN WE INITIALLY STARTED
LOOKING -- THERE WAS DURING THE
SCRAMBLE TO FIGURE OUT --
DIFFERENT NUMBERS -- WE HAD PROP
ONE UP A LOT OF PEOPLE WERE
TALKING ABOUT HOW PROP ONE WAS A
GOING TO BE ENOUGH TO FINISH
THEIR PROJECTS.
ON TO THE 2% WAS DERIVED AROUND --
THE ABILITY TO FINISH A SINGLE
PROJECT WITHIN PROP.
ONE ON THE NUMBERS KIND OF AND
HONE DOWN AND IT'S BEEN
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE LOOKED AT
THE WE'VE TALKED WITH DIFFERENT
GROUPS ABOUT.
ON THAT'S KIND OF WHERE WE'VE
ARRIVED.
SO THERE WAS NO ACTUARIAL STUDY
THERE WAS NO STUDY TO COME UP
WITH THIS THIS 2%.
THIS WAS JUST THE BETWEEN YOU
AND THE CHAIR AND HAVE AN
INFORMAL DISCUSSIONS.
ARMED AND DISCUSSIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS ALONG THE WAY OVER
THE LAST THREE YEARS THE LA --
HASN'T WAY DAN OTHERS HAVEN'T
WEIGHED AND THIS IS WE WE VAST
AND THEY SAID IT'S YOUR MADE A
FORMAL REQUEST TO THE LA -- ON
THIS [inaudible]
NOT.
NOT ON THIS AND I'LL.
NIGHT AND I GUESS I GUESS FOR ME
AND A GUY FOR ME A COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT I PROVIDE ABSOLUTELY
APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO -- AND I I TO HOLY UNDERSTAND
I'VE BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF A PRETTY
MUCH EVERY WATER.
WATER BILL THAT'S COME FORWARD I
UNDERSTAND UNDERSTAND WHERE
YOU'RE COMING FROM.
HOWEVER I LOOK AT MY OWN
DISTRICT -- WE ARE WATER DONORS
TO THE STATE.
YOU NOW TAKE 2% AWAY FROM THE
GENERAL FUND THAT'S 2% THAT WE
GET WE DON'T GET FOR OTHER
THINGS IN ART ALREADY POOR
DISTRICT.
LIKE OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
LIKE HEALTH CARE NEEDS.
IT'S A LOT OF MONEY ON AN
ONGOING BASIS -- AND WE ARE
ASKING TO TIE THE HANDS OF
FUTURE LEGISLATURE'S.
I THINK WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHICH I
ABSOLUTELY A HUGE SUPPORTER OF
EDUCATION -- THAT CREATES
CHALLENGES FOR US AT TIMES AS
WE'RE TRYING TO RAISE ADDITIONAL
REVENUE -- SO -- I ABSOLUTES
WHAT WERE YOU DOING BUT FOR
THOSE OF US IN AREAS WHERE WHERE
WATER IS NOT AN ISSUE WE ARE
SURE OUR WATER DONORS -- AND AND
AT TIMES WE HAVE WATER CRISIS OF
OUR OWN -- YOU'RE TAKING AWAY
MONEY FOR OTHER THINGS THAT THAT
MY FOLKS -- REALLY STRUGGLE WITH
WE CAN'T GET RESOURCES AROUND
FROM THE ENVIRO SCAN FOR FROM
FROM CARB -- BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
CONSIDERED BECAUSE WE BECAUSE WE
HAVE CLEAN WATER.
SO WE CAN'T GET SOME OF THE
RESOURCES YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO
GET IN OTHER PARTS OF YOUR
DISTRICT.
SO IF YOU DON'T MIND I KNOW IT
THE WRITING -- WHEN YOU KNOW
YOU'RE GETTING A GREAT POINTS
MISS WAS I'VE I'VE BEEN UP HERE
DISTRICT WITH YOU WE'VE WE'VE
GONE ON SEVERAL TURNS UP THERE
AND?
NOT SEEING THE WORK THAT THEY'VE
DONE WITH FISH TRIBUTARIES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT THE FUNDING
FROM THIS WOULD ACTUALLY HELP
COVER THE COST OF THOSE AND
ENSURE THAT -- YOUR WATER NEEDS
IN YOUR AREA -- STAY -- AS
PRISTINE AS THEY ARE AND WHAT
INSURE THOSE ECOLOGICAL SO WHO
WOULD DETERMINE THAT.
WHO WHO WHAT SO SO THE WAY THAT
ANY BREAKS OUT OR IS BETWEEN THE
STATE WATER BOARD ENDED UP YOU
ARE?
UNDER WHAT CRITERIA BASICALLY
FOLLOWING THE OUTLINE OF PROP.
ONE UNDER THE UNDER THE CURRENT
WATER BONG.
YEAH I GUESS -- YOU KNOW.
SITTING HERE NEXT TO ON MISTER
DALI ANIMATRONIC DRAG HIM INTO
THIS CONVERSATION ANYWAY.
BUT YOU KNOW WE STRUGGLE YOU
KNOW WE WERE FACING A WHILE FOR
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WE STRUGGLE TO GET YOU KNOW
WE WANTED THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR -- TO HELP
SUPPRESS WILDFIRES AND AND WE
STRUGGLE WE GOT TWO HUNDRED
MILLION A YEAR THE GOVERNOR'S
SINCE PUT IN ANOTHER HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR WHICH I'M.
REALLY THANKFUL -- FOR BUT YOU
KNOW THAT AFFECTS OUR WATER OUR
WATERSHEDS AND WITH THAT THAT
40% IS THAT GOING TO HELP WITH
FIRE SUPPRESSION EFFORTS ARE
FIRE PROTECTION EFFORTS IN IN MY
DISTRICT [inaudible]
CELL.
YOU KNOW I I ACTUALLY RAN A BILL
TO TAKE -- G. G. R. F. FUNDS
AWAY FROM HIGH SPEED RAIL WHICH
DOESN'T HELP YOUR DISTRICT
EITHER AND HAVE A GO TO CAL FIRE
TO HELP OUT WITH THE FIRES -- WE
HAVE SEVERAL FIRES AND MY
DISTRICT AS WELL.
AND I THINK THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
BEING DONE IN THAT AREA --
HOWEVER THERE'S NOT BEEN IN.
ENOUGH DONE AND WATER AGREED AND
2%.
VERSE IS BOND AFTER BON AFTER
BOND.
I THINK IS A VERY SMALL AMOUNT.
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE MADE A
PROMISE TO OUR CITIZENS THAT WE
WOULD TAKE CARE OF THEM WHEN IT
COMES TO WATER.
IN A INDUSTRY INDUSTRY SETS US
UP IN IN AN AVENUE WHERE.
EVERY DISTRICT ACROSS THE STATE
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE WATER
NEEDS ARE WHETHER IT BE
ENVIRONMENTAL.
WHETHER IT BE A BAD FIVE SLACK
WHAT LA IS DEALING WITH.
THIS PROVIDES ONGOING REVENUE.
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE
FUNDING NECESSARY TO DO WHAT IS
NECESSARY TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
WATER NEEDS.
SO AND I UNDERSTAND IT IN IN THE
NORTH DISTRICT YOU MIGHT FEEL
THE DAUGHTERS BUT YOU DO HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE UP THERE.
THE NEEDS TO TO ENSURE THAT THE
MAINTENANCE IS GOING ON AS I
MENTIONED IN MY EARLIER COMMENTS
WE DON'T NEED ANOTHER ORVILLE
SITUATION WHERE WE HAVE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE GO TO THAT POINT.
SO IT HATE TO SEE ANY LEVEES OR
CANALS -- ANYTHING UP IN YOUR
AREA AND NOT GET THE MAIN IS
THAT IT NEEDS -- AND SEE
SOMETHING LIKE THAT HAPPEN IN
YOUR NECK OF THE WOODS.
GREAT I JUST -- I I GUESS MY MY
TWO PRIMARY ISSUES IS -- WHERE
THE NUMBER COME FROM?
AND WHAT ARE THE ACTUAL NEEDS.
AND I'M JUST CONCERNED ABOUT IN
THE FUTURE TIE THE HANDS OF
FUTURE LEGISLATURES TO SOMETHING
THAT IS POTENTIALLY THREE THREE
BILLION POTENTIALLY THREE
BILLION DOLLARS THIS YEAR.
ANDIS THE BUDGET CONTINUES TO
GROW THAT NUMBER CONTINUES TO GO
UP.
AND I JUST I HAVE CONCERNS I
JUST TO SEE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO BUT I I'M I'M PROUD TO LAY
OFF TODAY [inaudible]
OUR WE HAVE -- CANTON.
TO THEN MR DOLLY THEN.
THIS IS ME THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
A TO THE AUTHOR AND THE CHAIR.
AM A MEMBER STAFF REALLY THE
SIGN ON FULL OF FULL FOCUS -- A
BALE.
OF MARK YOU KNOW IT.
GONE DOWN TO THE WATER BOARD IS
WHICH IS USED.
TURTLE IS TRYING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM THAT THAT YOU'VE YOU
BROUGHT TO WHO -- TO YOU. TO US
TODAY.
AND I HAVE A IN MY YEARS HOUSES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I HELPED A BIT
EVERY YEAR I HAVE BILLS TRYING
TO SOLVE THE GOOD DEAL THE WATER
YOU SHOULD.
MAKE SURE THAT WE EVERYBODY HAS
A FAIR SHARE AND AN UNTITLED WHO
WILL CLEAN DRINKING WATER AND SO
ON AND SO FORTH SO I AGREE.
WITH EVERYTHING YOU DO HAVE TO
AT BUT LIKE DOCTOR DOCTOR WOULD
I DO HAVE.
A YUSHU [inaudible]
WITH THE YOU KNOW DOING ARE THE
BUDGET BY A BALLOT BOX.
WE WE HAVE THE VERY -- YOUR I
DON'T KNOWS IS A PERFECT BUT WE
DO HAVE A PROCESS OF DID IT DID
THE ON DOING OUR BUDGET ON
ANNUAL BASIS -- PRECISE TYPING
AND TYING UP THEIR HANDS OVER
FUTURE -- LEGISLATURE.
I AM CONCERNING THAT -- THIS IS
THE SLOPE OF THE SLIPPERY SLOPE.
ALRIGHT I HAVE THE SAME PASSION
WAS TO WATER AS WELL AS FOR
EDUCATION.
AS WELL AS A PUBLIC SAFETY.
LEGAL CLIMATE CHANGE IN AND AS
WELL AS A TRANSPORTATION ISSUE.
IF WE ALL OWE YOU KNOW ARE ALL
THOSE IMPORTING ISSUE WOULD PUT
A FIXED NUMBER WEATHER.
IS A GOAL OF BY THE L. A. YOU
ARE YOUR CONSTITUENT A
STAKEHOLDER.
THEN YOU REALLY REALLY.
DEFEAT THE PROFITS OF OF WHAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE. TO TO TO
DETERMINE ON THE BUDGET ON THE
ANNUAL BASIS YOU KNOW WE KNOW.
THAT OUR REVENUE MADE OF
FLUCTUATE.
AND WE WANT TO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO MAKE THE DECISION.
LISTING INFORMATION AND
OVERSIGHT OVER TO FUND SHOW ARE
OF ALLOCATED.
SO OUR WORK -- I RESPECTFULLY --
AND STAY OFF ON ON THE ON YOUR
BILL TODAY.
SADDAM.
THEY MEASURE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SO --
I'M INTRIGUED BY THIS.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S LOTS OF ISSUES
IN THE STATE TO TO NEED
RESOURCES WITH WATER -- BUT I'M
ALSO.
SOMEONE WHO IS FOR MANY MANY
YEARS DONE BUDGETS THAT ARE
ALREADY COMPLETELY ALLOCATED OUT
AND THERE'S THE GENERAL FUND IS.
FOR GENERAL PURPOSE THANKS.
WHEN THERE IS NO GENERAL FUND
BECAUSE YOU'VE ALLOCATED IT THEN
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO DO A
BUDGET?
SO -- BUT I'M ALSO WANT TO SHARE
WITH THE THE AUTHOR THAT TOM.
YOU PICK THE NUMBER 2% WHICH I
THINK IN EUROPE IN THE ANALYSIS
I HAVE HERE WOULD BE LIKE TWO
POINT.
NINE BILLION DOLLARS THIS YEAR.
AND I HAVE CONSTITUENTS WHO IN
MYSELF ACTUALLY -- WHO HAS NOW
BEEN REGULATED BY THE I. R. M.
W. PEAS WHICH IS THAT YOUR
RELATED LANDS WHICH WE PAY WE
ARE TAXED?
A RECESSED A FEE SAME THING IS
MONEY OUT OF OUR POCKET TO DO
WATERSHED -- ANALYSIS BASICALLY
FOR THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD -- AND WE DO THIS.
IN ALL THE REGIONS OF THE STATE
SO THAT'S A TAX ON MY MY LAND
COULD BECAUSE I'M FARMING NOW WE
HAVE THE GROUND WATER.
THE SIGMA THE STATE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT PLANTS IF YOU'RE IN A
RAFT DOES THIS MONEY -- GONNA
OFFSET.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HAPPEN
TO PAY THOSE.
FEES AND TAXES NOW -- TO SUPPLY
BASICALLY BACKED BILL FOR THE
STATE WATER FOR THE THE THE
STATE.
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
THEMSELVES WE HAVE TO PAY AND
AND WE'RE WE'RE REGULATE
OURSELVES.
AND ON I WANTED ALSO TO ASK
ABOUT.
YOUR NORMAL CRISIS WAS.
DUE TO A LACK OF MAINTENANCE WE
KNEW THERE WAS A PROBLEM THERE
AND THE AND THE PEOPLE WHO
RECEIVE THE WATER ON THE OTHER
END SHOULD HAVE BEEN -- IN THE
BUREAU SHOULD HAVE BEEN DOING
THEIR JOB AND AND FIXING THEM
THE PROBLEMS THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED EARLIER IN THE IN --
THE EIGHT YEARS BEFORE BUT THEY
BUT THEY DO A DAY DATE NEGLECTED
TO DO THAT.
AND THE COST OF BEARING THAT
SHOULD BE ON THEM.
BECAUSE THEY DID MATE IT'S THERE.
IF A STRUCTURE THAT WAS THERE
BEFORE SO -- I'M INCLINED TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL BUT THERE'S A
LOT LACK OF A LOT OF DETAILS --
THEY NEED TO BE ADDRESSED AND SO
ARE YOU GONNA SAY THOSE PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN GROUNDWATER BASINS
SUCH AS YOURSELF THAT ARE
IMPAIRED.
ARE THEY GONNA HAVE TO BEAR THAT
COST -- THIS CALL IS THIS GOING
TO PAY FOR THAT AND WHAT WHAT IS
IT REALLY GONNA PAY FOR THERE'S
A LOT OF PROGRAMS OUT THERE THAT --
FOLKS ARE BEING TAXED ON AND
FEED -- ARE THOSE GOING TO GO
AWAY BECAUSE YOU'RE DEDICATING A
HECK OF A LOT OF MONEY -- EVERY
YEAR -- TO YOU KNOW CONTINUOUSLY
BE APPROPRIATED OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND.
SOME MEMORY.
WHAT CAN I GET AN ANSWER?
ARE YOU OR ARE YOU GOING.
TO ADMIT MR DOLL I GUESS I'LL
LET ME BREAK IT DOWN FOR YOU.
NUMBER.
ONE OR THE OTHER IS THIS MONEY
GOING TO BE DIRECTED IN EAR
MARKED IN THE DIRECTION THAT
GOES TO THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE IN
IMPAIRED GROUNDWATER.
RECHARGE SITUATION ARE ARE YOU
CAN OFFSET THAT COST ARE YOU
GONNA CONTINUE TO TAX THEM TO
MAKE THEM PAY FOR THEIR PROBLEMS
AND AND THEN TAKE THIS MONEY AND
GO I HAVE WELL INTENTIONED AND
TO TAX ANYBODY AND AND FORCE
THEM TO PAY MORE.
THE THE POINT OF TAKING OUT OF
THE GENERAL FUND IS THIS IS TAX
DOLLARS THAT ARE ALREADY THERE.
THIS IS MONEY THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE ALREADY PAYING --
IN REGARDS TO SIGNAL -- THERE
SEVERAL PROJECTS COMING UP --
WE'RE GROUND WATER RECHARGE IS
GONNA BE VITAL WE HAVE --
MILLIONS UPON MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF DEFERRED MAINTENANCE --
DUE TO THE LACK OF GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE.
AND THE RESULTS ON DEALING WITH --
THE SINKING OF LANDS.
ON AROUND THAT.
WE HAVE TO HAVE FUNDING FOR
THESE PROJECTS THAT WE'RE GONNA
NEED TO PUT IN PLACE TO MEET
SIGMAR REQUIREMENTS.
THAT'S ALL PART OF IT THAT'S WHY
THIS IS DESIGNED TO COVER ANY
AND ALL WATER PROJECTS.
SO WHETHER WE'RE DEALING WITH
SICK MORE PROJECTS WERE DEALING
WITH REDOING CITY INFRASTRUCTURE
WERE DEALING WITH -- MAINTENANCE
ON EXISTING -- CANALES DAMS
LEVEES EXCEPT RAW THIS IS
FUNDING TO BE PUT IN PLACE TO
COVER THOSE COSTS.
SO WE DON'T HAVE TO KEEP COMING
UP WITH NEW WAYS.
ON FOR OUR WATER DISTRICTS YOUR
CHARTER PEOPLE TO DO THIS ON US
FOR WE HAVE SEVERAL WATER
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION BECAUSE IT
ENSURES THAT.
WE HAVE A ONE WAY TO PULL
FUNDING FROM.
AND AGAIN A. AS THE L. AO.
STATED.
BY INTO REITERATE THEIR QUOTE --
YOU KNOW THEY SAY MOREOVER --
GENERAL OBLIGATION BONDS -- A
REPAID FROM THE GENERAL FUND
WITH INTEREST THEREFORE.
WOULD CAUSE THIS APPROACH TO BE
SOMEWHAT MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
DIRECT APPROPRIATIONS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND.
SO EVEN AT THE LA ALL THINGS
DIRECT APPROPRIATIONS.
THUS MARKING 2%.
WOULD BE A BETTER WAY TO GO THAN
WHAT WE'VE DONE OVER THE LAST
DECADE WHICH IS BOND AFTER BOND
AFTER BOUGHT HI WHAT WHAT'S IN
AGREE.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO ELECTION IS
IS.
MIKE I I TOTALLY GET THAT I KNOW
YOU'RE PAYING THE LOTTO FOR THIS
YES [inaudible]
OKAY.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY MUCH MORE
COMPLICATED AND AND I'D LOVE THE
DIVE INTO ANY DETAILS TO WORK
WITH YOU MOAN [inaudible]
FOR MR LIVING.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU -- YES
THIS IS THE WATER IS A LITTLE
BIT OF A COMPLICATED ISSUE --
AND WE THIS IS A YEAR FOLLOWING
A LOT OF YEARS WE'VE DUG
OURSELVES OUT OF A HOLE WHERE WE
DO HAVE AN AMAZING SURPLUS AND I
I WOULD BE COMPLETELY FINE IF WE
TOOK OUR CLEAN WATER CHALLENGES
AND DEALT WITH IT THIS YEAR.
AND I THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR SHOULD COME UP
WITH A PLAN. TO TAKE THIS STAIN --
FROM OUR STATE AND WIPE IT CLEAN
AND MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIAN HAS CLEAN DRINKING
WATER THIS YEAR BECAUSE WE CAN'T
DO IT THIS YEAR -- I DO HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH YOUR ACA -- THOUGH
I I I UNDERSTAND IT COMES FROM A
VERY GOOD PLACE.
YOU'RE QUITE FRANKLY.
THE THE DEDICATION OF A PERCENT
OF THIS BUDGET IS NOT JUST
LIMITING WHAT WE DO WITH THE
GENERAL FUND.
IT IS DIRECTING US TO CUT CHILD
CARE EDUCATION HEALTH CARE STATE
PARKS SOCIAL SERVICES THE LIST
GOES ON AS SOON AS THE BUDGET
GOES DOWN AND TAKES A DEBT -- IN
THE NEXT RECESSION.
IT IS GOING TO OCCUR SO YOU
WOULD BE NOT JUST FINDING OUR
HANDS ACTUALLY FORCING US. TO
WHACK THINGS THAT WE CARE A
GREAT DEAL ABOUT WHEN WE COULD
JUST HAVE THE POLITICAL WILL NOW
TO USE THE MONEY TO DO WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE TODAY.
WE ALSO DON'T HAVE A PLAN SO WE
HAVE A 2% 2% SOUNDS GREAT.
YOU CAN ARGUE WITH 2% A SOUNDS
LIKE BUDGET DUST THE WAY THAT WE
TALK.
ON WHAT IS IT THAT WE'RE GOING
TO SPEND THE MONEY ON HOW MANY
YEARS WILL IT TAKE US TO DO IT
2%.
FOREVER IS THAT EVEN THE RIGHT
AMOUNT WE DON'T KNOW.
BUT IF WE TOOK UP A PROP TO
APPROACH A RAINY DAY FUND
APPROACH WITHOUT ACTUALLY
PASSING A PROPOSITION BUT SANE.
WHEN THE BUDGET IS IN
CIRCUMSTANCES LIKE IT IS TODAY?
AND WE USE A PORTION OF THAT TO
WORK DOWN THAT PLAN.
THAT WOULD GET US ON A PATHWAY
TO SOLVING A LOT OF OUR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROBLEMS.
OF COURSE THE CHALLENGES WE
WOULD HAVE A LOT OF UNMET PLANS
THAT WE NEED TO DO FOR
CALIFORNIA -- SO OUR OUR TO DO
LIST IS PRETTY HIGH SO
APPRECIATE THE SPIRIT BY WHICH
YOU BROUGHT THIS.
JUST THERE'S NO PLAN.
IT BINDS OUR HANDS IN A WAY THAT
IN FACT FORCES US TO CUT.
SO MANY OTHER PROGRAMS THAT
CALIFORNIANS DEPEND UPON EVERY
DAY -- SO LET'S CONTINUE WORKING
ON THIS THANKS VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
THE MISSILES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS ABOUT
THIS APPRECIATE -- YOU BRING
THIS MEASURE BEFORE US I MEAN --
THE WAY I LOOK AT IT IS YOU KNOW
THE POPULATION CALIFORNIA'S GROW
TO OVER FORTY MILLION PEOPLE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE MAJOR
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
LEGISLATURE HASN'T?
UP WITH THE MONEY.
WITH THAT GROWTH.
SO I DON'T SEE IT AS A AS A CUT
TO OTHER SERVICES I SEE IT AS
YOU KNOW SAME THING WE DO WITH
PROPOSITION.
AT NINETY EIGHT FOR EDUCATION WE
SET ASIDE.
MONEY BECAUSE WE SAY THIS IS A
PRIORITY FOR THE STATE.
WATER IS ESSENTIAL FOR ANY
COMMUNITY TO GROW.
IT'S ESSENTIAL. FOR LIFE -- I
SEE THAT AS A THIS IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
ARE THE THINGS THAT WE CAN
RESOLVE IN THE LANGUAGE AND THE
LEGISLATION I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING -- THAT HAS SOME MERIT
AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
BUT I SEE THIS COMPLETELY AS AN
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA IN
CALIFORNIA'S INFRASTRUCTURE ONE
OF THE THE MAIN CHARGES. FOR US
I BELIEVE AS LEGISLATORS JUST TO
MAKE SURE THE GOVERNMENT WORKS.
AND AND TO ENSURE THAT
GOVERNMENT WORKS WE NEED TO HAVE
THE INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR
GOVERNMENT TO WORK AND I SEE
THIS IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION NOW BE VOTING I TODAY.
THANK YOU.
OKAY I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO ADD
MONEY -- SUPPORT.
AS WE HERE OUR WATER IS SO IS
CENSURED FOR OUR LIFE SUSTAINING.
AND THE AGRICULTURE AND WAS
STATUS -- HEAVILY -- DEPEND ON
THE PHONE OKAY WE CULTURE SO
THIS IS SO -- MANAGEMENT AND
BUILDING NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND ON OUR STATE -- HAS A WATER
PROBLEM -- AND THIS IS -- IS
ESSENTIAL.
OUR RESOURCES SELF FOR THE RIGHT
THE MANAGEMENT.
AND THE WHAT ARE THE PRIORITIES
SO CAN WE OF PUT AWFUL WATER
WATER AIR AND SUN LIGHT. TO
MAINTAIN -- OUR HUMAN LIFE SO
AND ON AGRICULTURE.
THE MEDIA ARE DEPEND ON NOW IN
THE WHOLE CALIFORNIA ALWAYS
ECONOMY SO I THINK THIS IS SO.
PROVIDING NECESSARY RESOURCES SO --
THAT THE PHOTO LONG TERM MORE A
DEFINITIVE PLAN AND THE TELLING --
PEOPLE THAT OUR GOVERNMENT IS A
SERIOUS ABOUT THE BY SETTING
ASIDE THAT THIS A SMALL AMOUNT
OF MONEY I THINK THIS IS.
NOT WEISS MANAGEMENT THE RATHER
THAN -- ISSUING AS YOU STATED
THE BONDS SO THAT THE LOCALLY
AND THAT THAT IS A ADDITIONAL
TAX.
WE HAVE EXPERIENCED A HUMONGOUS
SURPLUSES.
IN RECENT YEARS I THINK THAT
WOULD NOT THE HURT OR THE
PROGRAM SO -- AND IS NOT AN
EXCHANGE THIS IS STUFF BETTER
WISE UTILIZATION OF OUR EXISTING
NOW READ A BUDGETARY RESOURCES.
ARE THERE FOR I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
HI THIS MESSAGE THANK.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
OKAY -- SEEN NONE.
I THINK WE'VE HAD A GOOD
CONVERSATION HERE.
IRRESPECTIVE OF UP THE POSITION --
THAT -- MEMBERS HERE ON THIS
COMMITTEE HAVE -- PRESENTED THE
THE CHALLENGES THAT THEY SEE
WITH THE CURRENT -- LANGUAGE
WITHOUT HAVING YOU PRESENT THIS --
MEASURE.
WE DON'T GET THIS FEEDBACK.
HI -- IT SITS IN RULES AND
ULTIMATELY THE IDEAS OF TRYING
TO ADDRESS WHAT I THINK EVERYONE
HERE HAS SAID AND AGREED WE HAVE
A WATER PROBLEM.
INCALIFORNIA WHETHER IT BE AN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROBLEM.
OR FOR THAT MATTER A DIRECT A
PUBLIC HEALTH -- PROBLEM
PERTAINING TO PEOPLE NOT HAVING
CLEAN WATER.
RIGHT.
AND SO I APPRECIATE YOU STEPPING
INTO THE SPACE.
AND WANTING TO SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
IT MAY NOT BE THE ACA MAY NOT BE
SOME BILL TWO ONE SEVEN AND MAY
NOT BE THE SENATE BILL THAT IS
TRYING TO ADDRESS -- THE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER BUT I THINK THE
COMMON IS.
LET'S TRY TO FIX THIS PROBLEM
THIS YEAR -- WE HAVE SOME MONEY
IN THE BUDGET.
NOW WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT PROPOSALS THAT.
OUT PUT FORWARD TO SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING SOURCES.
I SEE THIS AS JUST ANOTHER
OPTION ON THE TABLE FOR US -- TO
DISCUSSED DELIBERATE DEBATE --
MISTER WOULD YOU BRING UP SOME
VERY GOOD POINTS AS IT RELATES
TO WHY 2%.
RIGHT MAYBE WE NEED TO DO SOME
MORE WORK ON FIGURING OUT WHAT
THE NUMBER IS I WOULD HOPE THAT
THE NUMBER DOESN'T COME BACK.
NEEDING TO BE 5%.
RIGHT THAT IT DOES.
I THINK THE POINT HERE OF
DEDICATING PERCENTAGES THAT WE
HAVE A SUSTAINABLE FUNDING
SOURCE.
AND THAT MAY NOT BE THE WAY THAT
PEOPLE FEEL COMFORTABLE
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM BUT THAT
IS A PROPOSAL RIGHT THAT WE
OUGHT TO LOOK AT THE DETAILS.
OF HOW THE MONEY IS SPENT IS.
THOSE ARE GOOD QUESTIONS --
PRIORITIZING REGIONS PROJECTS
AND AGAIN THE ONE MILLION PEOPLE
THAT DON'T HAVE SAFE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER I WOULD IMAGINE
WOULD BE.
AT THE TOP OF THAT LIST.
SO WE DON'T BRING THIS
RESOLUTION FORWARD THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THIS DISCUSSION -- AND WE
STAY ON THE SAME.
KINDA PAGER THE SAME PLACE --
ONE MORE YEAR -- WITHOUT HAVING
SOLVED THE PROBLEM OF FOR THE
MILLION PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE
SAFE CLEAN DRINKING WATER SO I
WANT TO COMMEND YOU I PUT MY
NAME ON THE RESOLUTION BECAUSE I
THINK -- PUTTING FORWARD AN IDEA --
IS IMPORTANT.
AND YOU TAKE THE RISK.
RIGHT OF THE TYPES OFCOMMENTS
AND FEEDBACK THAT THAT WE HAVE
HEARD TODAY.
WHETHER THEY BE CONCERNS.
OR THOSE WHO HAVE SAID HEY WE
SUPPORT -- THE CONCEPT MOVING
FORWARD AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT
IT IS IT IS A CONSTANT MOVING
FORWARD -- WHETHER OR NOT THIS --
MAKES IT TO THE FINISH LINE -- I
WOULD HOPE THAT YOU AND WE
COLLECTIVELY STAY ENGAGED ON
THIS ISSUE OF TRYING TO SOLVE%
CLEAN DRINKING WATER FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS THIS YEAR SO.
ALL UP CLOSE WITH THAT DID YOU
WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT.
I JUST WANT TO HAVE A SUPPORT
YOUR BILL BUT I HAVE A LOT TO
RESERVATIONS AND AND I RESERVE
THE RIGHT.
TO NOT VOTE FOR IT WHEN HE GETS
THE FLOOR IF IT'S NOT HAS A LOT
MORE DETAIL NEED A LOT MORE
DETAIL.
HI PLEASE CLOSE FIRA.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I I REALLY
DO APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
THE DIALOGUE AND HEARING THE
CONCERNS -- IN REGARDS TO THE 1%
I'M ALWAYS OPEN TO TAKE
AMENDMENTS.
I'M ALWAYS OPEN TO WORK WITH.
ANY AND ALL SIDES OF AN ARGUMENT.
TO SEEK THE BEST.
RESOLVE FOR OUR PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW AS WE ALL KNOW WATER IN
THE STATE IT IS A VERY HOLISTIC
THANK.
BECAUSE WE DEAL WITH WATER FROM
THE HEADWATERS WE COUNT OUR SNOW
PACK WE COUNT OUR RAINFALL.
WE HAVE THAT WATER COME DOWN.
WE CAPTURE IT.
WE CONVEY IT WE MOVE IT WE HAVE
VERY INTEGRATED SYSTEMS.
IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE.
WE HAVE CLEAN UP PROJECTS WE
HAVE ENVIRONMENTAL PROJECTS WE
HAVE WHAT WINS PROJECTS.
WE HAVE FOLKS ON THE COAST TO
DEAL WITH SALT WATER INTRUSION
ISSUES WE HAVE FOLKS IN LA THAT
ARE DEALING WITH THE PIPING
PROBLEMS THERE [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
DIFFERENT THINGS HAPPENING.
REGARDLESS OF WHERE YOU'RE AT
AND LOOKING AT THIS.
THIS WAS A WAY TO SAY.
OKAY GREAT WE HAVE THIS GREAT
BUDGET THIS YEAR.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE NEXT YEAR.
WHAT ABOUT FIVE YEARS FROM NOW?
WHAT ABOUT TEN YEARS FROM NOW
WHAT ABOUT FIFTY YEARS FROM NOW?
HOW ARE WE GONNA SET UP?
THE FUTURE OF OUR STATE. FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND OUR GRANDCHILDREN.
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO
BE SITTING IN OUR SEATS DECADES
FROM NOW.
WHEN THE POPULATIONS
[inaudible] EIGHTY MILLION
[inaudible]
OR LARGER.
WHAT OPTIONS WHATEVER STRUCTURE?
ARE WE GOING TO HAVE IN PLACE
WHAT KIND OF FUNDING SYSTEM ARE
WE GONNA HAVE. FOR THEM.
ARE WE GONNA HAVE.
HAVE PUT TOGETHER.
THE WATER PROJECTS THE
MAINTENANCE.
THE ONGOING FUNDING THAT IS
NEEDED TO SERVICE.
THE ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ARE WE GOING. TO MOVE FORWARD.
WITH SUCH A PLAN.
AND I BELIEVE.
ACA THREE IS THE WAY TO DO THAT.
WHETHER IT'S 2% WHETHER IT'S 1%
WHETHER IT'S FIVE OR 10%.
I DON'T REALLY CARE WHAT THE
PERCENTAGE IS WHAT I CARE ABOUT
MEMBERS AND WHAT WE SHOULD ALL
CARE ABOUT.
IS THE FACT THAT SOMETHING HAS
TO BE DONE.
WE KNOW BONDS ARE NOT THE WAY TO
CONTINUE FORWARD.
IN A DIRECT ALLOCATION. TO ME
SEEMS LIKE ONE OF THE MOST
VIABLE.
PROCESSES TO MOVE FORWARD WITH.
AND IT GUARANTEES IT. FOR THE
FUTURE OF OUR STATE AND EVERY
INDIVIDUAL HERE.
I'M ALWAYS OPEN TO AMENDMENTS IN
THE FUTURE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ALL.
MEMBERS I DO ASK FOR EITHER
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION I
THINK THIS WILL BE A MAJOR
MOTION.
NO -- WAS [inaudible]
GOOD OKAY.
WHICH IS SECOND PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AND WATER GARCIA.
AND WORD OF RCI GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW I CHOOSE A TROY.
CHOICE I TOO THE OLD BALLOT BOX
BUDGETING.
OUR I'M SORRY WHAT WAS THAT YEAH.
IT SHOULD KNOW.
DELHI.
DAILY I READ MEN.
FRIEDMAN NOT VOTING [inaudible]
CHRISTINA GARCIA.
CHRISTINA GARCIA NOT VOTING
GLORIA.
GLORIA NOT VOTING CHOLERA.
LEVINE.
THE VINO.
BLANCO REVEAL.
AKA REVEAL II SOLACE.
SOLACE I WOULD.
WOULD NOT VOTING. SEVENTY TWO
WHAT WILL LEAVE THE CALL OPEN
FOR A ONE MEMBER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LET ME BRING UP BACK THE FIRST
ITEM FOR FOLKS TO ADD ON MEANT
SECRETARY.
H. HERE [inaudible]
EIGHT FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
NUTRIA [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN I CHOLERA [inaudible]
SOLACE [inaudible]
SOLACE I TWELVE THIRTEEN WE HAVE
A WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
ANOTHER MEMBER.
TO CONSIDER ADDING ON OKAY.
WE ARE GOING -- TO KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR FIVE MINUTES -- FOR
OTHER MEMBERS FOR THESE FIRST
TWO ITEMS AND THEN WE WILL BEGIN
OUR US SPECIAL -- MEETING WITH
THE EL AL THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH
CALL FOR OTHER MEMBERS SAID
ON TO FIRST TWO ITEMS
[inaudible] THREE CHOLERA LEVEL
[inaudible]
AND THERE ARE.
EIGHT POLARA FIVE CHOLERA I
FOURTEEN OKAY THAT -- BILL WILL
MOVE TO APPROPRIATIONS.
GO STRAIGHT TO THE FLOOR THE
STACK WRECKED IT.
AC. EIGHT THREE SEVEN VOTES IN
FAVOR TWO AGAINST -- NOT
.
IS THERE A ANY OBJECTION TO
GRANTING RECONSIDERATION BY
UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
TO AC.
EIGHT THREE ANY OBJECTION TO
RECONSIDER [inaudible]
WILL RECONSIDER [inaudible]
CONSIDERATION.
RECONSIDERATION GRANT
[inaudible]
TO SO [inaudible]
OKAY.
NO WAY. TO ONE OF THE FAMILY.
OKAY SO AT THIS TIME -- WATER
PARKS AND WILDLIFE -- IS --
ADJOURN [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH -- WELL [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANKS AGAIN FOR LESS.
OKAY THEY'RE TRYING TO TRYING TO
FIND [inaudible]
HELLO [inaudible]
IF YEAH YEAH YEAH WE'RE WE
REALLY.
SET UP. THIRTY TWO YEAR.
IT LEADS. TO FIVE SEVEN ONE
THREE SIX EXACTLY.
I DON'T WANT THE ONLY THING
AROUND ME [inaudible]
RIGHT.
SO WE JUST GOT.
WITH THIS.
BILL -- DIVISION HOWEVER
[inaudible]
GOOD OKAY.
OKAY AGAIN NO GOOD MORNING WE'RE
GONNA START THE INFORMATION
HEARING BALANCING WATER NEEDS
INTO.
THE FUTURE THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY EXAMPLE WE'VE GOT -- TWO
PANELS WILL ASK -- THE FIRST
PRESENTER RACHEL WITH THE ALLEY
OWES OFFICE.
TO COME FORWARD.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AGAIN.
WHAT A WELCOME MAYA?
CHAIRMAN CORK DOCTOR WORK. FOR
JOINING US ALSO -- IN TODAY'S
HEARING.
PLEASE DROP AGAIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY GOOD MORNING RACHEL EHLERS
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S.
PASSING OUT A HAND OUT.
WHICH I WILL USE FOR MY
PRESENTATION I'VE BEEN ASKED TO
I THINK GIVE YOU SOME CONTEXT
BOTH FOR THE DISCUSSION YOU JUST
HAD AS WELL AS THE DISCUSSION
THAT YOU ARE ABOUT TO HAVE --
REGARDING FUNDING FOR WATER
RELATED ACTIVITIESSO -- I'LL
START WITH KIND OF AN OVERVIEW
OF EXISTING FUNDING WITH A
PARTICULAR FOCUS ON BONDS SINCE
THAT'S BEEN A BIG -- SOURCE OF
STATE FUNDING FOR WATER RELATED
ACTIVITIES AND THEN JUST TALK
VERY BRIEFLY ABOUT SOME IDEAS
AND CONSIDERATIONS FOR OTHER
OPTIONS FOR FUNDING WATER
RELATED ACTIVITIES.
AT IN OUR HAND IT IS ON OUR
WEBSITE M..
L. A. O. DOT CA DOT GOV FOR
THOSE WHO ARE NOT HERE IN THE
ROOM.
SO TURNING TO PAGE.
ONE OUR COLLEAGUE THAT PP I SEE
WHO YOU'LL HEAR FROM NEXT HAVE
DONE SOME WORK LOOKING AT
EXISTING FUNDING AND SPENDING ON
WATER RELATED ACTIVITIES AND
ESTIMATE THAT IT'S ABOUT THIRTY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
THE BULK OF THIS IS THAT THE
LOCAL LEVEL ABOUT 85% HALF FROM
LOCAL SOURCES SO WE TALK A LOT
HERE ABOUT STATE FUNDING FOR
WATER -- BUT REALLY THAT THAT IS
THE SMALLER SHARE ABOUT 12%.
OF PP I SEE ESTIMATES SO
CERTAINLY IMPORTANT -- AND
CERTAINLY THE BIGGEST PIECE
THAT'S IN YOUR PER PER VIEW AS
THE LEGISLATURE BUT ABOUT A
REALLY SMALL RELATIVELY PIECE OF
THE OVERALL -- PIE.
AND MOST OF THAT STATE FUNDING
IS RELATED TO BONDS EITHER IN
BOND FUNDING THAT GOES OUT EACH
YEAR OR IN GENERAL FUND FOR THE
DEBT SERVICE ON THIS MONTH'S
THERE IS SOME GENERAL FUND FOR
WATER RELATED ACTIVITIES TO BUT
MUCH MORE MINOR COMPARED TO THE
BONDS AND THE DEBT.
SERVICE.
SO TURNING TO PAGE TWO JUST
LOOKING AT WHAT THE RECENT BONDS
ARE AM AS YOU CAN SEE HERE THESE
ARE THE WATER.
AND NATURAL RESOURCES RELATED
BONDS OVER THE PAST TWO DECADES
TOTALING THIRTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS -- FOR VINCE THERE ARE
PIECES OF THIS THAT AREN'T WATER
YOU KNOW THERE'S SOME PARKS MANY
IN HERE AND HABITAT MANY IN HERE
AS WELL BUT BUT MOSTLY WATER
RELATED.
OUT MOST OF THE SPENDING AT IS
EITHER COMMITTED TO PROJECTS OR
ALREADY SPENT ON PROJECTS.
THE EXCEPTIONS DOWN SOME OF THE
MORE RECENT ONES.
AS WAS DISCUSSED AT LENGTH -- IN
IN YOUR PREVIOUS DISCUSSION
BONDS ARE NOT CHEAP MANY -- THEY
ARE THEY DO AT CARRIE INTERESTS
SO WE ESTIMATE THAT FOR ABOUT
EACH DOLLAR THAT IS BORROWED IT
COSTS ABOUT A DOLLAR AND THIRTY
CENTS WENT TO TAKE INTO.
ACCOUNT INFLATION PAID OVERTIME --
FROM THE GENERAL FUND FOR THAT
JOB ON DEBT AND WE'RE WE'RE
SPENDING RIGHT NOW ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR IT FROM
OUR GENERAL FUND. FOR BOND DEBT
AT JET SERVICE RELATED TO
NATURAL RESOURCES BONDS THAT
HAVE BEEN PASSED BY THE VOTERS.
SO TURNING TO PAGE THREE
FOCUSING A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
THOSE WATER COMPONENTS OF THOSE
RESET OF THE TWO MOST RECENT
BONDS YOU CAN SEE SOME OF THE
ACTIVITIES.
ARE THAT PROPOSITION ONE IN
PROPOSITION SIXTY EIGHT FUNDED
ARE RELATED TO WATER.
THAT SECOND CATEGORY THE WATER
SYDNEY BECAUSE SYSTEM PROTECTION
RESTORATION.
THERE MAY BE SOME IS THAT SOME
WOULD QUIBBLE WITH SOME OF THOSE
PROJECTS BEING WATER RELATED BUT
THERE'S A CLOSE NEXUS THINGS
LIKE AS AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT
BROUGHT UP -- WATERSHED HEALTH
AND WATERSHED -- FOREST
MANAGEMENT THAT THAT CAN BE
RELATED TO WATER BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S WHERE MOST OF
OUR WATER ORIGINATES -- SO OF
THESE FUNDS FOR PROPOSITION ONE
MOST OF IT HAS BEEN THE VAST
MAJORITY HAS BEEN APPROPRIATED
BY THE LEGISLATURE AND MOST OF
IT IS COMMITTED TO PROJECTS
ALREADY KIND OF SPOKEN.
FOR PROP SIXTY EIGHT OBVIOUSLY
JUST PASSED LESS THAN A YEAR AGO
SO THERE'S STILL A LOT MORE OF
THAT MANY KIND OF AVAILABLE.
BUT IF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSALS ARE ADOPTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR IT WILL BE
ABOUT HALF OF PROP SIXTY EIGHT
THAT WILL BE APPROPRIATED
ALREADY EVEN WITHIN THE FIRST
YEAR -- OUT FOR PROJECTS.
AND THEN JUST A NOTE I THINK
THIS WAS ALSO DISCUSSED A BIT
EARLIER BUT BOND FUNDS ARE
USUALLY USED FOR LARGE PROJECTS
THAT -- ARE PAID FOR OVERTIME
NOT USUALLY USED FOR ONGOING
ACTIVITIES LIKE OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE ON THEIR SEVERAL
REASONS FOR THAT ONE IS THAT
IT'S ONE TIME MANY SO IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE TO COMMIT FOR AN
ONGOING PURPOSE -- AND ALSO
BECAUSE IT IS FUTURE TAXPAYERS
WHO ARE PAYING FOR IT BIG WITH
THE INTEREST OVER TIME IT MAKES
SENSE FOR IT TO BE.
SPENT ON LARGE PROJECTS THAT
THOSE FUTURE TAXPAYERS WILL ALSO
BENEFIT FROM.
SO TURNING TO PAGE FOUR ALTHOUGH
WE HAVE ALL OF THIS EXISTING
FUNDING AS HAS BEEN A BIG THEME
OF YOUR DISCUSSION TODAY --
THERE ARE STILL A LOT OF NEEDS --
DESPITE THESE FUNDS M..
THEY RESULT FROM AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE GROWING
POPULATION.
INCREASE AND REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS -- AND THERE ARE A
LOT OF CONSTRAINTS ON THE ON THE
FUNDING AND AND ABILITY TO RAISE
EXISTING ADDITIONAL FUNDING --
THAT IS BOTH RELATED TO CAPACITY
IN CERTAIN AREAS SOME
COMMUNITIES THAT CAN'T RAISE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING BECAUSE OF
THE CHARACTERISTICS OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS
REQUIREMENTS AROUND HOW YOU CAN
RAISE ADDITIONAL FUNDING THROUGH
PROPOSITION TWO EIGHTEEN
PROPOSITION TWO TWENTY SIX
PROPOSITION. THIRTEEN SOME OF
THESE -- CONSTRAINTS THAT VOTERS
HAVE CHOSEN TO PLACE AROUND THE
ABILITY TO RAISE ADDITIONAL
REVENUES -- SO WE HAVE BEEN
ASKED MANY TIMES AND YOU HAVE
DISCUSSED MANY TIMES SOME OF
THESE OTHER OPTIONS AS JUST.
WAS ALLUDED TO BY THE CHAIR SO
HERE ON PAGE FOUR WE HAVE SOME
OF THE OPTIONS THAT ARE
REGULARLY TALKED ABOUT BY THE
LEGISLATURE -- THERE ARE STATE
LEVEL FUNDING SOURCES USUALLY.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
RAISING THE REVENUES IT'S EITHER
FEES WHICH ARE DIRECTLY RELATED
TO HOW THE FUNDING WILL BE USED?
OR TAXES -- WHICH AS OFTEN MORE
RELATED TO HOW THE FUNDING IS
GENERATED -- SO THEIR REGULATORY
FEES OR CHARGES.
RELATED TO WHO THE RESPONSIBLE
PARTIES ARE -- WILL BE TAXES
RELATED TO THE BENEFICIARIES ARE --
AND BRENDA BROAD TAXES AND THEN
ALSO AS WAS JUST DISCUSSED
LOOKING AT EXISTING FUNDING AND
HOW YOU WANT TO DEDICATE SOME OF
YOUR EXISTING FUNDING.
NAMELY THE GENERAL FUNDS THAT
COULD EITHER BE THROUGH EXIT AT
INCREASING EXISTING SPENDING
LEVELS DEDICATING PERCENTAGES AS
YOU JUST DISCUSSED OR IF YOU
CHOOSE TO AN ACNE BONDS THAT
ULTIMATELY HAS A GENERAL FUND
EFFECT AND IS.
REALLY THE RESULT.
pADDITIONAL SPENDING FROM GENERAL
FUND.
THEY'RE ALSO ACTIONS YOU CAN
TAKE TO AUTHORIZE LOCALS TO BE
ABLE TO GENERATE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THAT WOULDN'T BE KIND OF
AUTOMATIC THESE TWO AT THE
BOTTOM.
BUT WOULD PROVIDE MORE THIRTY
FOR LOCALS THESE HAVE BEEN
TALKED ABOUT TRYING -- TO ADOPT
SOME CONSTITUTIONAL CHANGES THAT
WOULD ALLOW MORE FLEXIBILITY AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR RAISING
REVENUES.
SO TURNING TO PAGE.
FIVE JUST SOME BROAD
CONSIDERATIONS AS YOU MAY BE
THINKING ABOUT SOME OF THESE
OPTIONS -- AND WANT TO FIGURE
OUT WHICH ARE THE **** MOST
APPROPRIATE THESE ARE SOME OF
THE CATEGORIES THAT WE WOULD
REALLY ADVISE YOU THINK ABOUT --
AND THE FIRST IS WHAT WHAT
PROBLEM ARE YOU TRYING TO SOLVE
WHAT ACTIVITIES DO YOU WANT TO
UNDERTAKE AND THAT CAN HELP
GUIDE SOME OF THE REVENUE
OPTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT WANT TO
THINK ABOUT.
WHO ARE THE RESPONSIBLE PARTIES
WHAT WOULD YOU BE UNDERTAKING
WITH THE FUNDING?
REALLY THINKING ABOUT THE
BENEFICIARIES AND RESPONSIBLE
PARTY SO YOU CAN DRAW THAT NEXUS
BETWEEN THE FUNDING WHO'S
BENEFITING FROM IT IF IT'S A
BROAD ACTIVITY THAT STATE WIDE
YOU MIGHT WANT TO THINK ABOUT A
MORE BROAD -- SOURCE OF FUNDING
COMPARED TO IF THERE'S A BENEFIT
REALLY AT THE REGIONAL LEVEL ARE
FOR ONE PARTICULAR CATEGORY OF
OF ENTITY -- AND THEN THINKING
ABOUT HOW THAT FUNDING WOULD BE
USED AS AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION TO PARTICULARLY IF
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT -- FUNDING
AT THE STATEWIDE LEVEL WITH
PROPOSITION TWENTY SIX IF IT'S A
FEE THE USE OF THE FUNDING HAS
TO BE REALLY RELATED -- TO THOSE
WHO ARE PAYING THE FEE.
I HOW MUCH REVENUE DO YOU NEED
IF IT'S A FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR A YEAR PROBLEM THEN
PURSUING A REVENUE OPTION THAT
RAISES FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR PROBABLY ISN'T WORTH IT.
AND WON'T GET YOU THERE AND ALSO
THINKING ABOUT THE VOLATILITY OR
STABILITY OF THAT REVENUE AS
WELL IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
FINDING SOMETHING LIKE
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE WERE
STAFF WILL BE HIRED AND THE
NEEDS OF THE SAME EVERY YEAR.
BUT YOU PURSUER HAVE REVENUE
SOURCE THAT MAY BE REALLY
VOLATILE EACH YEAR THEN YOU MAY
RUN INTO PROBLEMS SO LINKING UP
AGAIN THAT NEXUS OF WHAT IS THAT
FUNDING COMING FROM AND HOW
EXACTLY DO YOU WANT TO USE IT
WHAT PROBLEM ARE YOU TRYING TO
SOLVE.
RIGHT SIZING THE SOLUTION WITH
THE PROBLEM.
AND THEN FINALLY TURNING TO PAGE
SIX THINKING ABOUT SOME OF THE
NITTY GRITTY.
ENACTMENT AND IMPLEMENTATION
CONSIDERATIONS OF SOME OF THESE
OPTIONS.
WHAT WITH THE VOTE REQUIREMENTS
BE WHAT KIND OF DATA IS
NECESSARY -- IN ORDER TO ENACT
SOMETHING AS SOME SOME OF THESE
OPTIONS AND IS THAT AVAILABLE
HOW COMPLICATED WOULD IT BE --
TO IMPLEMENTED IF IT TAKES A LOT
OF ADMINISTRATION AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN A LOT OF FUNDING IT'S
ONLY RAISING A COUPLE MILLION
DOLLARS IS THAT WORTH IT.
SO THINKING ABOUT SOME OF THOSE
CONSIDERATIONS.
HOW MUCH LATITUDE WILL WOULD
THERE BE OVER HOW THE FUNDING IS
USED VERSUS HOW MUCH YOU WANT TO
PRESCRIBE HOW THE FUNDING IS
USED AND THEN WHAT OVERSIGHT
WOULD THERE BE FOR YOU AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY BUT ALSO FOR
THE PUBLIC TO KNOW HOW FUNDS ARE
USED AND?
AND HOW THEY'RE BEING
IMPLEMENTED.
SAY I THINK THE BIG TAKE AWAY IS
THAT THERE IS QUITE A BIT OF
FUNDING AVAILABLE NOW FOR WATER
RELATED ACTIVITIES BUT ALSO.
QUITE A BIT IN NEEDS THERE ARE
OPTIONS FOR YOU AS A LEGISLATURE
TO BEGIN TO ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS.
BUT YOU REALLY NEED TO THINK
CAREFULLY ABOUT WHICH OF THOSE
OPTIONS YOU WANT TO PURSUE AND
HOW WELL IT ALIGNS WITH THE
PROBLEM THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE.
SO AGAIN JUST SOME CONTEXT BOTH
FOR THE DISCUSSION YOU JUST HAD
BUT I THINK YOU'RE GONNA HEAR
ABOUT SOME NEEDS IN YOUR IN YOUR
NEXT PRESENTATION SO STARTING TO
THINK ABOUT HOW YOU MIGHT WANT.
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE NEEDS.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AND OF COURSE ALWAYS HAPPY TO BE
HERE AS A RESOURCE FOR YOU.
ANYONE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
KHAN COMES YES SIR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
AND MUCH OF IT HAS. TO DO WITH
THE FUNDING IN THE TORAH BONDS --
CURRENTLY.
A USUAL US A COMPREHENSIVE --
PICTURE OF THAT THE YOU FOR HERE
LISTENING TO A SEE A NUMBER --
THREE WHAT IS YOUR ASSESSMENT OF
A 2% OF OUR GENERAL FUND SET
ASIDE THE PHOTO OF WHAT --
ACTIVITIES AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
DO YOU.
HAVE A IN THE ON OUR LOSSES SO.
WHEN THE BECAUSE SAID THERE WERE
A LOT OF QUESTIONS OF?
WHETHER THAT THE 2% IS A RIDE
TOMORROW. TOO MUCH WHAT TOO
LITTLE -- DO YOU HAVE ANY
OPINION ON THAT.
OUR OFFICE DOES NOT TAKE A
POSITION ON BILLS -- AND WE
HAVEN'T LOOKED CAREFULLY AT AC
THREE IN THE NEEDS I KNOW THAT
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME STUDIES M.
M. PPC MAY BE ABLE TO COMMENT ON
THIS BECAUSE THEY'VE DONE A LOT
OF WORK AT LOOKING AT SOME OF
THE CATEGORIES OF FUNDING THAT
IT KIND OF OUR FUNDING.
ORPHANS IS HOW THEY HAVE TURNED
THEM THAT THAT DON'T HAVE A A
STREAM OF FINDING.
THINGS LIKE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE SARSI CAN
WATER -- FLOOD MANAGEMENT IS
ANOTHER ECOSYSTEM SO I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE SOME CATEGORIES OF
ACTIVITIES AND SOME ESTIMATES
OUT THERE FOR SOME OF THOSE
CATEGORIES BUT BUT OUR OFFICE
HASN'T TAKEN A CAREFUL LOOK AT
AC THREE OR QUANTIFIED THE NEED.
LISTENING TO THE DISCUSSIONS SO
WHILE AGO DO YOU PLAN TO HAVE A
SOME ANALYSIS ON THAT -- 2%
SUGGESTION -- WE DON'T TYPICALLY
DO ANALYSES OF OF EVERY SINGLE
BILL THAT COMES THAT'S USUALLY
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
THAT COMES WERE HAPPY TO BE A
RESOURCE TO THE LEGISLATURE IF
YOU HAVE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS --
TO WORK WITH YOU.
THAT'S SO VERY DIFFICULT --
POSITION FOR YOU TO TAKE -- I'M
NOT ASKING FOR IT TO TAKE ANY
POSITION BUT THE ANALYSIS OF
WHETHER THAT AMOUNT THAT WOULD
SOLVE ALL WALK ON WATER RELATED
ISSUES.
SO THAT THE NOVEL QUESTIONS SO
THAT THE RAISED UP BY THE MEMBER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- CANDY AND
SODA -- WITH THE SOME NOW --
VALID POINTS SAID THAT TO YOU
YOUR DEPARTMENT DOES.
IS SO THAT THE ANNA BASED UPON --
YOUR ANALYSIS OF THAT AMOUNT OF
MONEY WHAT KIND WHAT.
PROBLEMS THAT THAT WAS.
WHETHER THAT'LL BE TOO MUCH WORK
THOSE.
TWO OF TOO SHORT.
NO.
OBVIOUSLY WE DO HAVE -- WATER
ISSUES I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE TO
TRY TO SOLVE WHEN THE LOCALLY --
SPORADICALLY HERE HAPHAZARD MASS
THOUGHT THE THAN NOT COORDINATED
I HAVE PHOTO LOCALLY THROUGH
ISSUING BONDS SO -- SO THESE.
ARE THE TWO PERCENTAGE
SUGGESTION OUR DEDICATED TO
EVERY EVERY YEAR THAT WAS
SOMEWHAT OF A LONG TERM.
BASED UPON THE POPULATION GROWTH
THE PROJECTIONS SO.
AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS A
FAILING -- SO I THOUGHT THAT
THAT WAS SO GOOD THE LONG TERM
ARE ESSENTIAL.
PLANNING FOR OUR STATE.
BUT THE SURPRISING ME -- THEY
TOOK DIFFERENT POSITIONS SO
THAT'S WHY.
THAT'S WHY -- I THOUGHT THE YOUR
DEPARTMENT SO.
ANALYSIS OF THAT THE WEATHER
THAT THE AMOUNT 22% IS A VALID.
IT MAKES SENSE OR NOT THAT MAY
HELP.
YEAH I MEAN I GET AGAIN WE DON'T
HAVE A PRACTICE OF DOING
ANALYSES OF EVERY SINGLE BILL
BUT AT ME IF THERE ARE SPECIFIC
REQUESTS THAT COME TO US WE CAN
LOOK AT THAT A DOCTOR.
I TIRE OF I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED BY THE AUTHOR.
OR AUTHORS OF THE BILL --
WHETHER IT BE SPECIFICALLY -- TO
ACA THREE OR JUST IN GENERAL
WANTING TO KNOW WHAT ARE THE
OUTSTANDING INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
OF THE STATE AND SO WE CERTAINLY
WILL WILL CONSIDER THAT.
AND I THINK WHEN WHEN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION TO AS AS AS AS I
ALLUDED TO THE END OF THINKING
ABOUT WHAT IS THE PROBLEM WHAT
IS THE SOLUTION NOT ONLY LOOKING
AT WHAT ARE THE NEEDS BUT WHAT
IS THE FORECAST FOR THE GENERAL
FUND IN THE FUTURE -- YOU KNOW
YOU'D WANT TO KIND OF LINE THOSE
UP AS WELL [inaudible]
HIS OFFICE.
THANK YOU MISTER I WAS JUST
GONNA KIND OF ASK.
MAYBE TO HELP -- SOMEONE OVER
TROY.
OF THE BONDS THAT YOU LOOKED AT
BECAUSE YOU HAVE SEVERAL LISTED
EVEN ON PAGE. TWO ONE TWO THREE
FOUR THERE'S LIKE SEVEN OR EIGHT
OF THAT OF THE THE BONDS THAT
WERE ISSUED TO ME WHAT WAS.
HOW LONG BEFORE THEY WERE
ACTUALLY FULLY UTILIZED?
THAT MAKES SENSE YEAH SO.
IT GENERALLY WELL THEY'RE
GENERALLY KIND OF PAID OFF OVER
THIRTY TO FORTY YEARS -- PARTLY
THAT'S BECAUSE THEY'RE USUALLY
PAID ON A REIMBURSEMENT BASIS SO
USUALLY TAKES A COUPLE OF YEARS
TO GET THE PROGRAMS KINDA UP AND
RUNNING AND THEN FOLKS APPLY FOR
THEM AND THEN THEY GET THE GRANT
AWARDS.
AND THEN THEY UNDERTAKE THE
PROJECTS AND THEN THEY GET PAID
BACK.
AND THEN THE STATE PAYS FOR THEM
SO IT TYPICALLY IS YOU KNOW OF A
FEW DECADES UNTIL THEY'RE ALL
YOU CAN SEE HERE.
I EVEN ON THIS CHART THERE ARE --
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN IN MARCH
TWO THOUSAND SET AT TWO THOUSAND
WAS PASSED BY THE OTERS THERE
ARE STILL DOLLARS IN THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL THAT WILL BE BEFORE YOU
IN JUNE OF SPENDING PROP
THIRTEEN DOLLARS SO.
IT TYPICALLY DOES TAKE --
SEVERAL YEARS FOR THOSE DOLLARS
TO GET FULLY UTILIZED.
BUT AS WE'VE SEEN WITH PROP ONE
THAT JUST PASSED IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN NEARLY ALL OF THOSE
DOLLARS NOT QUITE ALL OF THEM
BUT MOST OF THEM HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED TO SPECIFIC PROJECTS
NOW SO I THINK THERE IS.
CLEARLY A LOT OF DEMAND OUT
THERE BUT IT DOES TAKE AWHILE
FOR ALL THE DOLLARS TO GET KIND
OF FULLY UTILIZED.
GOT IT MAYBE THAT JUST SPEAKS TO
THE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS.
OF THE STATE KIND OF INFORMING
OUR PREVIOUS DISCUSSION.
ABOUT -- THE HUGE NEED.
SO I GUESS ONE THING FOR US TO
CONSIDER AS WE MOVE FORWARD IS
THE DEBT SERVICE THAT WERE
PAYING ON THE BONDS AS OPPOSED
TO A DIRECT ALLOCATION. FOR
INVESTMENT APPRECIATE THAT I
THINK UP WITH ANY THAT'S PART OF
THE PURPOSE OF HAVING THAT
CONVERSATION RIGHT.
IS TO THE BILL DO A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS OF HOW WE'RE PAYING FOR
IT RIGHT -- WHETHER OR NOT --
IT'S FINANCIALLY FEASIBLE TO
CONTINUE.
TO USE THE SAME PRACTICE BUT
THAT WAS THE PRIOR CONVERSATION
AND AND NOW.
WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS I I DID
HAVE A QUESTION AND AT WHAT
POINT DO YOU THINK -- THE ALLEY
OLD OFFICE IS IN A GOOD POSITION --
TOO BUT ANALYZE -- VIA A REQUEST
YOU KNOW -- D. DIRECT --
ALLOCATIONS -- BY [inaudible]
YELP POPULATION BY REGION -- BY
NEED AND THERE'S ALWAYS THIS
QUESTION.
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT?
NEW FUNDING MECHANISMS ARE NEW
BONDS
WELL WE ALREADY FUNDED THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HEAR QUITE
OFTEN WE WE ALREADY FUNDED THAT --
WE ALREADY -- DID THAT BUT IT
NEVER MADE IT TO IT'S INTENDED --
PURPOSE SO I THINK AT SOME POINT
AND DOUBT WHEN IS THE QUESTION.
IS IT APPROPRIATE FOR THE ALLEY --
TO LOOK AT UPON LIKE.
SIXTY EIGHT RIGHT THE MOST
RECENT ONE TO BE ABLE TO GO BACK
AND LOOK AT ITS INTENTION.
AND ULTIMATELY IT'S OUTCOMES --
SO PLEASE CAN AT NIGHT HELP ME
IT YEAH I THINK M. AND TO SOME
REMEMBER SAUCES QUESTION IT DOES
IS.
PROBABLY TOO PREMATURE FOR PROP
SIXTY EIGHT SINCE THOSE DOLLARS
ARE STILL GETTING OUT THE DOOR --
YOU MAYBE EVEN A LITTLE EARLY
FOR PROP ONE BUT WE COULD START
SEEING SOME OF IT -- SOME OF THE
EARLIER ONES MAYBE BECAUSE IT
DOES TAKE SO LONG TO GET THE
DOLLARS AND SO LOOKING AT WHAT
PROJECTS WERE FUNDED WHERE WHERE
THOSE PROJECTS FUNDED.
DID THE PROJECTS -- ACHIEVE WHAT
THEY INTENDED I THINK SOME OF
THE DISCUSSION AND I AND I CAN'T
RECALL FORGIVE ME IF IT WAS BEEN
IN THIS WHEN I'VE BEEN BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE BUT SOME OF THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEES OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL MONTHS.
HAVE STARTED ASKING -- REALLY
GOOD QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW DO WE
KNOW THAT WE'RE ACHIEVING WHAT
WE WANT TO ACHIEVE PARTICULARLY
IN THE IN A CHANGING CLIMATE AND
TRADITIONALLY WITH BONDS THE WAY
WE HAVE EVALUATED THAT IS.
YOU SAID YOU WERE GOING TO DO
THIS PROJECT DID YOU DO THE
PROJECT YES CHECK DONE.
BUT I THINK MOVING A LITTLE BIT
MORE INTO SOME OF THE AREAS OF
WHAT DID WE WHAT WERE OUR
INTENTIONS AND DID WE ACHIEVE
THOSE INTENTIONS IF WE WANT A
PARTICULAR FOR SOME OF THESE
ECOSYSTEM PROJECTS FOR LOOKING
FOR MORE RESILIENT -- ECOSYSTEM
AND FOR BEING RESTORING WETLANDS
THAT WE WANT TO HELP -- BUT FOR
WELL OKAY SO YOU RESTORE THE
PROJECT BUT BUT DID ACHIEVE THAT
OUTCOME AND I THINK THAT GETS A
LITTLE HARDER BECAUSE IT'S EASY
TO SAY DID YOU BUILD A WATER
PLANT YES PEOPLE TO WATER PLANT
WERE DONE.
IF YOU'RE TRYING TO GET AT SOME
OF THAT OUTCOME BASED -- YOU
HAVE TO YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
DIFFERENT MEASURES YOU HAVE TO
BRING SCIENCE INTO A LOT MORE
AND YOU HAVE TO PROBABLY HAVE SO
MANY FOR ONGOING MONITORING SO.
I THINK WE WOULD PROBABLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO THINK ABOUT
THAT PARTICULAR IF YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT NEW BONDS
BUILDING THAT IN TO TRY AND
START LOOKING AT DID YOU NOT
JUST SAY WHAT YOU SAID YOU WERE
GOING TO DO BUT DID YOU DO WHAT
WE WANT YOU TO DO AND AND YOU.
HAVE TO STRUCTURE THAT A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENTLY I THINK.
OF COURSE.
THIS BILL OF JUST HAVING WORKED
ON ONE OF THOSE WATER BONDS AND
AND KNOWING.
WHAT YOU JUST SAID THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL REALLY
WANTED TO GET DOWN BUT?
COULDN'T GET THAT DONE OR SIGNED.
BY THE GOVERNOR IF WE PUT THAT
TYPE OF LANGUAGE IN THERE I
THINK MR SOLACE IT'S IN A PRETTY
SQUARE ON THE HEAD THERE.
WE REALLY HAVE TO START LOOKING
AT A MORE PROACTIVE DEDICATED
BAND OF FUNDING SOURCE -- FROM
THE FROM THE GENERAL FUND IF YOU
WILL I THINK THAT'S WHAT THE
CHAIR WAS TRYING.
TO LOOK AT WHAT WE CERTAINLY
DON'T WANT TO GO TO THE AT AS MR
QUIRK IS MENTIONED AND OTHERS
MENTIONED EARLIER.
WE DON'T WANT TO GO TO THE
BALLOT BOX -- FOR EVERYTHING WE
DO WANT TO RESERVE THE RIGHT TO
BE ABLE TO CONTROL THE PROBLEM
IS WE DON'T HAVE THE DISCIPLINE
TO CONTROL.
WE TEND TO SHIFT OUR PRIORITIES.
WITH THE WHIMS OF WHATEVER'S
HAPPENING AT THE MOMENT.
FORGETTING THINGS WHICH OFTEN
CAUSES INCREASES IN COSTS.
WHICH CAUSES US TO RUN OUT OF
MONEY THAT WE DON'T HAVE. TO
BEGIN WITH.
SO I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
COMPLICATED -- DISCUSSION HERE.
BUT I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
BRIGHT MINDS.
IN THE LEGISLATURE THAT CAN SIT
DOWN AND HAVE A SYSTEMATIC
LOGICAL DISCUSSION AND ACTUALLY
PUT THIS TOGETHER.
ON A FROM A BIG HOLISTIC PICTURE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS YOU COULD
CONSIDER IT CONCEPTUALLY IS IF
YOU'RE UNDERTAKING A LARGE
PROJECT IN YOU NEED KIND OF A
BIG UP FRONT AMOUNT OF MONEY
WHICH USUALLY IS WHAT WE AS
BONDS.
FOR THEN PAIRING IT WITH AN
ONGOING STREAM THAT COULD LOOK
AT SOME OF THAT NOT ONLY THE
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE BUT
ALSO SOME OF THE SCIENTIFIC
MONITORING AND THINKING ABOUT
THOSE KIND OF IN COMBINATION.
IF WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE A FUN
SOURCE WHICH KEEPS US IN CHECK
SO THAT WE DON'T GET.
BEHIND AS WE ARE CURRENTLY TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER GELLER.
SO I I KNOW SO WE WE CAN
OUTLINED SEVERAL DIFFERENT.
TYPES OF FUNDING SOURCES -- ONE
ONE THAT I WAS BEEN THINKING
ABOUT IS WHAT IF WE DID ALLOW
LOCALS TO KEEP MORE OF THEIR
SALES TAX -- I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
IF YOU LOOKED AT THAT CONCEPT
BUT MAYBE IN ADDITION TO SOME OF
THESE OTHER THINGS THAT COULD BE
ANOTHER.
WAY TO HELP FUND SOME OF THESE.
MANY OF THEM ARE YOU USUALLY
LOCALLY FOCUSED ALTHOUGH THEY DO
HAVE.
A STATEWIDE IMPACTS AS WE NOW.
BUT THAT MIGHT AT LEAST ALLOW
THEM TO KIND OF KEEP SOME OF
THEIR OWN MONEY THAT'S BEING
GENERATED LOCALLY AND PUT INTO
THESE PROJECTS IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT WAS ANALYZE IT ALL WE
HAVEN'T LOOKED AT THAT I MEAN
OBVIOUSLY IF IT'S SPENDING
THAT'S COMING TO THE STATE NOW
AND IT.
STOPS COMING TO THE STATE IT
WOULD HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE
STATE ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY RELYING ON IT BUT
CERTAINLY THERE ARE NUMEROUS
OPTIONS.
UP FOR REVENUE STREAMS AND AND
AGAIN I THINK WE WOULD SUGGEST
THINKING ABOUT.
THE STATEWIDE VERSUS LOCAL NEXUS
IS PROBABLY A ONE HELPFUL TOOL
YOU COULD USE AS A WEIGHING
THOSE OPTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
WE APPRECIATE YOUR WAYS -- A
STEPPING UP TO THE PLATE.
FOR OUR PURPOSES OF INFORMING.
A PROCESS OR THE LEGISLATURE IN
GENERAL ON THESE VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUES THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE NEXT
PANEL TO COME UP.
I THINK THAT THAT TAKE A FEW
MINUTES TO SET UP BY A POWER
POINT THOUGH FOR BOARD
PRESENTATION -- SO WE WILL --
GIVE THEM SOMETIME BY THE SET UP
.
ALL RIGHT I THINK -- WE'RE JUST
BY YEAH I THINK SO OKAY.
THANK YOU.
SIR.
JIMMY JUST CLICK ON OKAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. FOR FOR HAVING US
HERE I'M I'M ELLEN HANNEKE I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE WATER POLICY
CENTER AT PUBLIC POLICIES TO
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE WITH TWO OF
MY GOOD FRIENDS AND AND CO
AUTHORS ON THIS.
ON THIS WORK THAT WE'RE TO BE
TALKING TO YOU ABOUT SARGE GREEN
FROM FRESNO STATE AN AND TIMES
HARDER FROM.
FROM UC DAVIS AND UC COOPERATIVE
EXTENSION AND OTHER THINGS --
TOO REVEALED I I'LL GET IT WRONG
IF I IF I DON'T LIST THEM ALL
BUT SO SO WHAT WHAT WE ARE ARE
ARE GOING TO DO IS GIVE YOU UP A
LITTLE BIT OF AN OVERVIEW OF
THIS.
STUDY THAT WE THAT WE JUST CAME
OUT WITH A COUPLE OF MONTHS AGO
THIS IS BEEN PART OF A THREE
YEAR EFFORT.
ON THAT A TEAM OF US HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON TO LOOK AT THE THE
WATER SUPPLY AND QUALITY
CHALLENGES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AND AND LOOK FOR SOME
PROMISING SOLUTIONS AND SO I
JUST -- WANTED TELL YOU WHAT
YOU'VE GOT IN FRONT OF YOU THANK
YOU THERE ISN'T THERE'S A
OVERVIEW PIECE THIS ALSO EXISTS
IN SPANISH -- THE KIND OF
HIGHLIGHTS ALL OF THE FINDINGS
OF THE REPORT -- YOU'VE GOT ALSO
THE SLIDE THAT I'M GOING TO SHOW --
YOU GOT A COUPLE OF PIECES OF
WRITTEN TESTIMONY FROM SERGEANT
MYSELF AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE FOR
ANYBODY WHO WHO LIKES OF PAPER.
THIS IS ALL AVAILABLE ONLINE BUT
WE HAVE THE FULL COPY OF THE
REPORT WHICH WHICH CAN BE USEFUL
HAS A LOT OF GREAT GRAPHICS IN
IT SO HAPPY TO TO LEAVE SOME OF
THOSE WITH YOU.
I'M SO LET ME JUST KICK OFF FOR
YOU I WANT TO INTRODUCE THE THE
THE THE TEAM REALLY QUICKLY THIS
WAS A COLLABORATIVE EFFORT.
BETWEEN OUR ORGANIZATIONS FRESNO
STATE UC DAVIS PP I SEE AS WELL
AS YOU SEE MERCED AND POINT BLUE
CONSERVATION SCIENCE.
AN INTERDISCIPLINARY TEAM ANDWE
WORKED OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS --
WITH THE WITH THE GOT GOT A LOT
OF GOOD GUIDANCE FROM AN
ADVISORY GROUP OF FROM FOLKS
AROUND THE VALLEY THIS IS NOT TO
BLAME THEM FOR ANYTHING AT THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING ABOUT
BECAUSE THEY MAY OR MAY NOT
AGREE WITH IT BUT THE BIT THEY
PROVIDED.
TO US WITHOUT A LOT OF REALLY
GOOD FEEDBACK ALONG THE WAY AND
GAVE US A YOU GET WE'RE GOOD
SOUNDING BOARD AND AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATED THAT.
THAT INPUT FROM THEM -- SO THE
THE BIG PICTURE IS THE YOU KNOW
FOR TALKING ABOUT KIND OF WATER
WATER CHALLENGES IN STATE THIS
IS THIS IS REALLY GROUND ZERO IN
IN IN A LOTTA RESPECTS -- FOR
ADDRESSING MANY OF THE THINGS
THAT ARE THAT ARE BECOMING THE
IN FRONT OF YOUR COMMITTEE --
THIS YEAR THIS IS THE STATE'S
LARGEST FARMING REGION OVER HALF
OF OF ALL -- FARM GATE REVENUES
ARE ARE FROM THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY THE EIGHT VALLEY COUNTIES.
A LOT IS AT STAKE IN TERMS OF
ADDRESSING THE CHALLENGES OF
WATER SUPPLY AND WATER QUALITY
FOR THE REGION'S ECONOMY FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT -- AND WE FIND THAT
THE MOST PROMISING APPROACHES
OUR APPROACH IS THAT REALLY HELP
INCREASE FLEXIBILITY.
TO MANAGE THE WATER AS AS AS
BEST AS POSSIBLE PROVIDE
INCENTIVES ESPECIALLY TO
LANDOWNERS IN GROWERS WHO ARE
GOING TO BE.
ON THIS SORT OF FRONT LINE IN
TERMS OF OF MANAGING THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT.
ACT IMPLICATIONS APPROACHES THAT
LEVERAGE MULTIPLE BENEFITS THE
TRY TO KIND OF STACKED STACKED
DIFFERENT BENEFITS WITH WITH --
ONE YOU KNOW ONE ONE KIND OF
INVESTMENT ARE ARE GOING TO BE
MORE MORE IMPORTANT AND WE'LL
TALK ABOUT A FEW EXAMPLES OF
THAT.
AND THEN WHAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT IS THAT THIS IS REALLY
SOMETHING AS SOMETHING
FUNDAMENTALLY ADDRESSING THESE
CHALLENGES GOING TO HAVE TO BE
LED BY.
FOLKS IN THE REGION ARE AT THE
LOCAL AND REGIONAL LEVEL AND
THEY'RE GOING TO DO BEST WITH
COOPERATION AND COORDINATION.
BUT THAT THE STATE AND FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTS CAN BE REALLY REALLY
KEEP PARTICIPANTS SO WE'RE GONNA
TRY TO GIVE YOU SOME SENSE OF
WHERE IN PARTICULAR THE STATE
CAN BE ESPECIALLY HELPFUL.
SO -- BIG CHALLENGES ARE WHAT
ONE OF THEM IS WATER SUPPLY AND
THIS IS A MAP OF THE OUT BASINS
THAT HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THE
SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT.
AND DEVELOP PLANS TO ADDRESS
GROUND WATER SUSTAINABILITY
EVERY BASE AND THAT'S SHOWN UP
THERE IN AN ORANGE OR IN YELLOW --
IS CONSIDERED PRIORITY AND HAVE
HAS TO A REPLY THAT THE RESPONSE
TO THIS -- THE VALLEY IS MOSTLY
IN ORANGE THERE YOU CAN SEE AND
THAT'S BECAUSE ALL MOST OF THESE
BASES ARE CONSIDERED CRITICALLY
OVER DRAFTED BY THE DEPARTMENT
WATER RESOURCES WE ESTIMATE THAT.
THE LONG TERM DEFICIT IS ABOUT
TWO MILLION ACRE FEET A YEAR ARM
WHICH CORRESPONDS TO ABOUT 11%
OF NET WATER USE IN THE IN THE
WHOLE BASE AND THERE ARE A LOT
OF CONSEQUENCES OF THIS THAT ARE
THAT ARE -- IMPACTING.
CREATING HARM IN THE VALLEY DR
WELLS BOTH DRINKING WATER AND
IRRIGATION WELLS WE SAW THIS A
LOT DURING THE LAST ROUTE
SINKING LANDS WHICH IS AFFECTING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
A LOT OF THE BIG CONVEYANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT ALSO FLOOD
CONTROL INFRASTRUCTURE AND THEN
JUST READ CONCERN ABOUT REDUCE
SUPPLIES FOR FUTURE DROUGHTS
BECAUSE GROUNDWATER IS IT IS A
GREAT DROUGHT RESERVE WHEN THE
SURFACE WATER.
IS NOT AS A PLANET FULL
GROUNDWATER REALLY COMES IN
HANDY NOW THE VALLEYS ON A FAST
TRACK OF FOR IMPLEMENTING SIGMA
BECAUSE THE THE CRITICALLY OVER
DRAFTED BASINS ARE THE ONES THAT
HAVE TO GET THEIR PLANS IN FIRST.
THOSE PLANS ARE DUE IN TWO OF
THE PART OF WATER RESOURCES IN
JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY AND BASICALLY THE
TWENTY TWENTY YOUR TIME LINE TO
TO IMPLEMENT AND ATTAIN
SUSTAINABILITY -- AND THE MASS
OF THIS IS IS A SIMPLE IN A WAY
THE SOLUTIONS ARE TOUGH BUT THE
MATH IS SIMPLE IF YOU'RE IN AN
OVERDRAFT BASIN.
YOU'VE GOT TO EITHER FIND MORE
WATER ADD SUPPLY.
OF OR USE LESS OR PROBABLY IN A
LOT OF THESE BASE IN SOME
COMBINATION AND SO -- THIS IS
GOING TO CAUSE SOME SHORT TERM
COSTS EVEN THOUGH THE LONG TERM
IMPLEMENTATION OF CIGNA IS GOING
TO BE GOOD FOR THIS REGION
BECAUSE THAT MEANS THE READ THE
RESOURCE WILL BE THERE. FOR FOR
THE GENERATIONS TO COME AND SO
WE LOOKED AT HOW TO DO THIS IN A
WAY THAT COULD BE.
A LEASE PAINFUL AND AND MOST
BENEFICIAL SO THAT'S THE SUPPLY
SIDE NOW.
THE SUPPLIES THAT HAS TO BE
MATCHED WITH WHAT'S HAPPENING ON
THE QUALITY SIDE AND EVEN.
THOUGHT I KNOW TALKING A LOT
ABOUT THE SAFE DRINKING WATER --
CHALLENGE THAT'S A MAJOR ISSUE
IN THIS VALLEY TO SHOW YOU A
COUPLE MAPS OF THAT IN A MOMENT --
BUT THEY'RE ALSO JUST LONG TERM
ISSUES OF AND WE WE WE'RE WE'RE%
ARGUING THAT PROVIDING SAFE
DRINKING WATER JUST AN URGENT
THING THAT WE JUST HAVE TO DO.
PRONTO ARM AND THEN BUT THEY'RE
ALSO LONGER TERM WATER QUALITY
MANAGEMENT ISSUES INCLUDING
NITROGEN LOADING WHICH IS A YOU
KNOW AN ISSUE IN ANY
AGRICULTURAL AREA.
OF THEIR SOME NITROGEN THAT THAT
CONTRIBUTES TO THE TO THE GROUND
WATER AND IN PARTS OF THE VALLEY
IT'S VERY VERY HIGH -- AND
CAUSES CONTAMINATION OF DRINKING
WATER AND THEN MANAGING LONG
TERM SALT BALANCE WHICH IS AN
ISSUE FOR AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTIVITY.
SO THERE ARE POTENTIAL SYNERGIES
IN MANAGING OF FIRST OF SUPPLY
GROUND WATER BALANCE AND AND FOR
MANAGING QUALITY BUT THEY'RE
ALSO SOME POTENTIAL TRADE OFFS.
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
RECHARGING GROUNDWATER WE'LL
TALK ABOUT THAT A LITTLE BIT
MORE IN A MOMENT.
AND THEN THE THIRD ISSUE THAT WE
HIGHLIGHT OUR THE AS REALLY
FORTHCOMING AND TALK ABOUT
DRINKING WATER QUALITY IN THE
LONG TERM WATER QUALITY AS
SEPARATE ISSUES -- IN TERMS OF
POLICY SOLUTIONS THE FOURTH KIND
OF AREA WE'RE WE'RE GONNA
HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU A LITTLE BIT
IS THE NEED TO THINK ABOUT HOW
YOU GET BENEFITS FOR PEOPLE IN
NATURE IN THE MIDST OF THIS
TRANSITION ESPECIALLY.
WHEN -- RECOGNIZING THAT SOME
LAND IS LIKELY TO COME OUT OF
PRODUCTION AS PART OF DEMAND
MANAGEMENT.
IN THE VALLEY AND THERE'S A LOT
OF CONCERN ABOUT WHAT THIS COULD
MEAN IN TERMS OF ADDITIONAL DUST
ADDITIONAL PASS ADDITIONAL WEEDS
ARE BAD FOR PUBLIC HEALTH BAD
FOR NEIGHBORING FARMS -- AND SO
INTEREST IT VERY EARLY DAYS OF
INTEREST IN LOOKING AT HOW DO WE
MANAGE THAT THOSE DECISIONS IN
WAYS THAT ARE.
ARE GOING TO BE AS BENEFICIAL AS
POSSIBLE AND AND PROVIDE AS MUCH
VALUE TO THE VALLEY SO LOOKING
FOR MULTI BENEFIT APPROACHES
HEALTHY SOILS MANAGEMENT WHICH
COULD GENERATE CREDITS FOR FOR
CARBON CAPTURE -- HABITAT OF
SOLAR INCLUDING WILDLIFE
FRIENDLYSOLAR RECHARGE CAN BE
AN IMPORTANT THING TO TO LOOK AT
IN SOME PLACES FLOOD PROTECTION
RECREATION THESE ARE ALL THINGS
TO THINK ABOUT IN TERMS OF
MANAGING MANAGING LAND AND WATER
RESOURCES.
SO I'M GOING TO JUST WALK
THROUGH FOR YOU.
THESE FOUR AREA FOR PRIORITY
AREAS FOR ACTION.
AND A LITTLE BIT OF KIND OF SOME
OF THE SOME OF THE KEY AREAS IN
NEED IN EACH OF THESE HAT WE
THINK.
KIND OF NEAT NEED TO HAPPEN IN
ORDER FOR FOR SICK FOR SUCCESS
THE FIRST IS BALANCING WATER
SUPPLIES AND DEMANDS SO THIS IS
THIS ISSUE OF ADDRESSING THE
LONG TERM GROUNDWATER OVERDRAFT.
AND WE LOOKED IN THIS STUDY AT
PRETTY MUCH ANYTHING THAT
ANYBODY HAD EVER COME OUT WITH A
REPORT ABOUT OR ANALYSIS ABOUT
IN TERMS OF SUPPLY OPTIONS.
WE LOOKED AT THOSE TO SEE HOW
MUCH WATER COULD BE MADE
AVAILABLE IN THE VALLEY FROM
THAT BUT ALSO HOW MUCH WOULD IT
COST BECAUSE WE WANTED TO SEE IN
PARTICULAR HOW MUCH OF THIS
COULD BE AFFORDED.
BY FARMERS WHO WILL BE THE THE
PRINCIPAL FOLKS AFFECTED BY BY
MANAGING.
SIGMA JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE THE
THE MAIN WATER USERS IT'S A IT'S
A BIG BIG SECTOR IN THE VALLEY
YOUR GATED AGRICULTURE WE ALSO
LOOKED AT THE MAN MANAGEMENT
OPTIONS BOTH FOR AGRICULTURE BUT
ALSO IN THE URBAN SECTOR -- AS
WELL AS WAYS TO INCREASE
FLEXIBILITY AND JUST THE THE
IDEA DOES THAT I'M GOING TO TALK
ABOUT WHEN I WHEN I SHOW YOU
NEXT GRAPH IS.
THINKING ABOUT THAT THAT READ
PART OF THAT DOUGHNUT THERE THE
GROUNDWATER OVERDRAFT FEES --
EITHER YOU GOTTA FIND SUPPLIES
TO FILL THAT.
OR YOU'VE GOT TO REDUCE THE
DONUTS. TO TO TO SHRINK THAT
OVER TIME UNDER SIGMA.
AND SO THIS IS JUST A SNAPSHOT
OF WHAT WE FIND ON THE SUPPLY
SIDE THIS IS LOOKING AT A WHOLE
LOT OF DIFFERENT PROJECTS
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS BOTH BIG
AND SMALL.
ARM IN DIFFERENT CATEGORIES THE
BLUE BARS TO SHOW YOU HOW MUCH
WATER PHYSICALLY COULD BE
AVAILABLE POTENTIALLY AT THE YOU
KNOW THE MAXIMUM POTENTIALLY
AVAILABLE ON AN ANNUAL AVERAGE.
OF FROM FROM THESE FROM THESE
DIFFERENT ACTIVITIES AND THE
YELLOW IS THE IS THE PORTION
THAT WE THINK OF IT FARMERS ARE
LIKELY TO BE WILL BE ABLE TO
AFFORD AND AND WILLING TO PAY --
FOR RATHER THAN WRAP IT IN IN
THE IT ISSUE BEING IF IT'S MORE
COSTLY THAN THAT.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE MAKING
ENOUGH MONEY IN THERE FOR IN
THEIR FARMING FROM IT AND SO
THEY WOULD THEY WOULD NOT BE AS
INTERESTED IN INVESTING.
IN YOU STARTING TO SEE THE THESE
CONVERSATIONS HAPPENING ACROSS
THE VALLEY IN TERMS OF WHAT.
OF WHAT FOLKS ARE WILLING TO
INVEST IN SO I'LL JUST WALK YOU
THROUGH REALLY QUICKLY KIND OF
WHAT THE WHAT THE BIG.
THE BIG CATEGORIES ARE CAPTURING
AND STORING MORE MORE LOCAL RUN
OFF THIS IS THIS KEY ISSUE OF
WINTER AND SPRING FLOOD FLOWS
SOME OF IT IS NOT.
A REQUIRED FOR THE ENVIRONMENT
SOME OF IT IS NOT REQUIRED FOR
DOWNSTREAM WATER USERS -- CAN WE
CAPTURE MORE OF THAT AND GET
THAT.
INTO THE GROUND.
ESPECIALLY BUT YOU KNOW ALSO
ALSO WINS IN SURFACE RESERVOIRS
WHAT WE FIND IS THAT THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE BIGGEST.
AFFORDABLE POT OF WATER -- ABOUT
21% OF THE OF THE DEFICIT COULD
BE MET IN THAT WAY ESPECIALLY
WITH GROUND WATER RECHARGE.
THE SECOND BIG CATEGORY THERE IS
INCREASING RUN OFF WITH UPPER
WATERSHED MANAGEMENT.
YOU CAN SEE THAT THAT'S A BIG
BLUE BAR THERE'S QUITE A LOT OF
POTENTIAL WATER UP THERE BUT
THAT'S VERY EXPENSIVE IF YOU
JUST ARE THINKING ABOUT AS
INVESTMENT FOR WATER ALONE.
THIS IS YOU KNOW MANAGING YOUR
HAD WATER FOR US TO TO INCREASE
RUN OFF.
THE THIRD IS INCREASING DELTA
IMPORTS AND THERE WE LOOKED AT
CAL CALIFORNIA WATER FIX WE
LOOKED AT SITES RESERVOIR WE
LOOKED AT SHASTA.
A VARIETY OF THINGS AND WHAT WE
FIND IS THAT THERE'S MOST OF
THOSE BIG PROJECTS ARE KIND OF
EXPENSIVE ON A PER ACRE FOOT
BASES FOR FARMERS.
AND WHICH IS WHY YOU HAVEN'T YET
SEEN MANY PEOPLE SIGNING UP FOR
THAT IN THE VALLEY EITHER SO
THAT WE DO THINK THOUGH THERE'S
SOME COST EFFECTIVE POTENTIAL.
TO MANAGE THE WHOLE SYSTEM IN A
MORE COORDINATED FASHION AND AND
GET SOME GET SOME GET SOME
ADDITIONAL WATER OUT OF THAT THE
OTHER THE OTHER CATEGORIES ARE
PRETTY SMALL IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME ALL OF SKIP OVER THOSE BUT
WE CAN COME BACK IF YOU HAVE
QUESTIONS.
SO THINK ABOUT THIS AS ABOUT A
QUARTER OF THE DEFICIT CAN BE
MET WITH AFFORDABLE NEW NEW
SUPPLIES THAT MEANS THAT ABOUT
THREE QUARTERS OF THE DEFICIT
HAS TO BE MET THROUGH DEMAND
MANAGEMENT OR WILL LIKELY HAVE
TO BE MET THROUGH DEMAND
MANAGEMENT.
AND THE MAIN WAY THAT THIS CAN
HAPPEN IS WITH SOMEWHAT WITH
CROP SHIFTING BUT ESPECIALLY
WITH TAKING SOME LAND OUT OF
PRODUCTION.
ARM AND THAT'S BECAUSE YOU'RE
GAY ASIAN EFFICIENCY DOES NOT
REALLY GET YOU MUCH IN THE WAY
OF NET WATER SAVINGS WHICH IS
WHAT YOU NEED. FOR BASE AND
BALANCING YOUR CATION EFFICIENCY
HAS ALL KINDS OF OTHER
ADVANTAGES BUT IT'S NOT A GREAT
STIGMA TOOL.
SO WHAT THESE LITTLE BAR SHOW
YOU IS JUST A COMPARISON OF HOW
TO MANAGE.
THAT DEMAND IN WITH.
INFLEXIBLE OR FLEXIBLE WATER.
USE AND THE THE MOST INFLEXIBLE
INFLEXIBLE BAR THAT GRAYBAR AS
ARE THE I GUESS IT'S BROWN --
THAT IS IF BASICALLY FARMERS IN
A BASIN THAT HAS LET'S SAY 25%
OVER DRAFT WHICH IS KIND OF WHAT
THEY'RE ESTIMATING ROUGHLY IN
KERN.
ARM IF EVERYBODY JUST HAS TO CUT
EVERY CROP BY EXACTLY 25%.
YOU DON'T MAKING CHOICES OF OKAY
I'M GOING TO LEAVE MORE WATER
FOR A MORE PROFITABLE CROP AND
LESS FOR ANOTHER -- THAT IS THAT
THAT'S THE MOST COSTLY BY FAR
AND WE ESTIMATE YOUR RELATIVE TO
CUT CURRENT CONDITIONS THAT
WOULD COST ABOUT.
A LOSS OF REVENUES OF ABOUT
THREE POINT FIVE BILLION.
DOLLARS A YEAR IF YOU JUMP TO
THE NEXT -- THE ORANGE THERE
THAT IS A MATTER OF ALLOWING FOR
LOCAL WATER TRADING FLEXIBLE
WATER USE BOTH SURFACE WATER AND
GROUNDWATER WITHIN THE BASINS
WITHIN THE GROUNDWATER BASIN SO
LOCALLY -- THAT CUTS THE REVENUE
LOSSES ALMOST IN HALF.
JUST BY GIVING THAT FLEXIBILITY
TO TO TO USE THE WATER WHERE IT
IT'S BRINGING IN THE THE MOST
REVENUES.
ON PROFITS -- AND THEN THE THE
OR THE YELLOW IS WHEN YOU ALSO
HAVE VALLEY WHY TRADING WITHIN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY SAME
WATER BUDGET BUT JUST ALLOWING
SURFACE WATER TO MOVE AROUND.
FROM SOME OF THE BASINS THAT
DON'T HAVE A BIG OVERDRAFT
PROBLEM TO THE TO SOME THAT DO.
AND THEN THE BLUE IS KIND OF THE
OF IT ARE NOW SAYS THE SWEET
SPOT THAT'S THE COMBINATION OF
THE FLEXIBLE WATER MANAGEMENT
ALONG WITH THOSE SUPPLY
INVESTMENTS AND WHAT YOU CAN SEE
IS THAT THAT.
BRINGS THE THE REVENUE LOSSES
DOWN THERE ONLY ABOUT A QUARTER
OF WHAT THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN
WITH INFLEXIBLE WATER USE AND NO
SUPPLY INVESTMENTS.
THAT'S ALSO THE ONE THAT REALLY
REDUCES LAND FOLLOWING BECAUSE
THAT JUST MEANS MORE WATER IS
AVAILABLE TO APPLY.
TO TO THE CROP SO THE ESTIMATES
THAT HAVE BEEN REPORTED FROM OUR
STUDY OF AT LEAST HALF A MILLION
ACRES THAT WE ANTICIPATE MAY
NEED TO GO OUT OF CROP OF YOUR
GATED.
CROP PRODUCTION THAT'S THAT BLUE
BAR IT'S ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND ACRES IF
THERE'S NOT NEW SUPPLIES WERE
LOOKING MORE LIKE.
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND SO
THE OTHER -- THING TO NOTE IS
THAT THESE THINGS THESE MORE
FLEXIBLE STRATEGIES AND THE NEW
SUPPLIES -- YOU COMBINE THOSE
THAT'S GOOD NOT ONLY FOR FARMERS
IN IN TERMS OF CROP REVENUES IT
ALSO IS IS GOOD FOR THE REGIONAL
ECONOMY IN IN A MORE GENERAL WAY
WE LOOKED AT BOTH THAT BEEF AND
AND DAIRY.
AT DOWNSTREAM PROCESSING AND AND
KIND OF THE ECONOMICS OF THAT
NOT JUST FROM THE FORMER
PERSPECTIVE BUT ALSO FROM.
REGIONAL A G. P. AND ALSO FOR IT
FROM THIS PERSPECTIVE A JOBS
IT'S JUST BETTER. TO TO KIND OF
USE THIS PORTFOLIO APPROACH TO
TO REDUCE THE COSTS THE OTHER
KEY FLEXIBILITY TOOL THAT FOLKS
ARE IMAGINING OR ENVISAGING
USING IN THE VALLEY IS WHAT
THEY'RE CALLING A GLIDE PATH.
THIS IS THE IDEA THAT YOU DON'T.
OVERNIGHT AND OVERDRAFT YOU TAKE
YOUR TWENTY YEARS TO AND
GRADUALLY GET THERE THAT GIVES
YOU MORE TIME TO ADAPT AND
ADJUST AND KIND OF DO PILOT
PROJECTS. TO TO SEE WHAT'S
WORKING [inaudible]
SO -- PRIORITIES THIS IS KIND OF
A A LIST OF THE OF THE DIFFERENT
KINDS OF THINGS THAT ARE NEEDED
TO MAKE THE SUPPLY AND DEMAND.
A PORTFOLIO WORK THERE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT THAT NEED
TO HAPPEN WHICH IS HIGHLIGHTED
FOR YOU HERE THE ONES WITH STARS
ARE WEIRD STATE AND FEDERAL
ACTION ARE ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT.
THAT'S IN HELPING TO ASSESS
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS WHERE ARE
THE GOOD INVESTMENTS THAT'S KIND
OF ONE OF THE FOLLOW ONS TO THE
DISCUSSION YOU HAD ON FUNDING
THIS MORNING IS HOW TO FIGURE
OUT.
YOU KNOW THERE THERE'S THE LIST
OF POTENTIAL PROJECTS IS WAY
BIGGER THAN THAN THE MONEY NO
MATTER WHAT YOU DO SO WHERE'S
THE WHERE'S THE BEST BANG FOR
THE BUCK -- NUMBER FOR
CLARIFYING HOW MUCH WATER IS
AVAILABLE FOR RECHARGE THIS KIND
OF THE THE LEGAL QUESTION AND
THAT'S REALLY. ONE WHERE THE
STATE NEEDS TO TO PLAY A VERY
IMPORTANT NEW LEADING ROLE AND
THEN NUMBER FIVE IS FACILITATING
APPROVALS FOR TRADING AND
BANKING PROJECTS THAT'S USING
STATE INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL AS
FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE. TO TO
MAKE SOME OF THESE.
THESE DEALS HAPPEN -- AND THEN
YOU KNOW IT WORKING WITH LOCALS
ON SOME OF THESE OTHER THINGS I
THINK TO THE HELP THAT HELP
ENCOURAGE THEM TO DEVELOP THEIR
OWN.
THEIR OWN -- NCENTIVES AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
SO NEXT IS INSURING SAFE AND
RELIABLE DRINKINGWATER AND IF
THE VALLEY IS GROUND ZERO FOR
GROUND WATER OVERDRAFT AND
SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT.
IT'S ALSO GROUND ZERO FOR THE
SAFE DRINKING WATER CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THIS IS BOTH A QUALITY
ISSUE AND A SUPPLY ISSUE I HEARD
ABOUT YOU REPORTER BILL THIS
MORNING.
THAT'S ON THE SUPPLY SIDE THAT
THAT WOULD BE -- EIGHT A IS THE
JUST LOOK A LOOK AT COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS THAT WERE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WITH A VERY IS
MAXIMUM CONTAMINANT LIMITS THIS
IS MATT FROM JULY OF LAST SUMMER --
THERE WOULD BE SOME ADDITIONAL
DOTS ON THERE FOR ONE TO THREE
T. C. P. NOW AS WELL AND WHAT
WE'VE HIGHLIGHTED THE THEY'RE
THE EIGHT VALLEY COUNTIES.
OVER HALF OF ALL THE SYSTEMS ARE
THAT ARE OUT OF COMPLIANCE ARE
ARE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
AND MOST OF THESE SYSTEMS ARE
SMALL AND MOST OF THEM HAVE BEEN
OUT OF COMPLIANCE FOR AT LEAST
THREE YEARS SO IT'S A IT'S NOT
JUST THE A BLIP KIND OF PROBLEM
WITH A CHRONIC PROBLEM.
AND THEN IF YOU LOOK AT MATT B.
THIS IS THE DAY THAT THE STATE
COLLECTED DURING THE DROUGHT OF
SYSTEMS MOSTLY SYSTEMS WAS
SHALLOW WELLS THAT THAT WERE
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE.
TO A TWO GOING DRY WHEN THE
GROUND WATER LEVELS WERE FALLING
THE THE BLUE IS THE HOUSEHOLD
THAT REPORTED TO THE STATE
WEBSITE ABOUT HAVING SHORTAGES
WITH WITH THEIR DOMESTIC WELLS.
AND THE ORANGE IS SMALL SAYS OR
SYSTEMS THAT REQUESTED EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE FROM THE STATE
COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS HALF OF
THOSE COMMUNITY WATER SYSTEMS
THAT HAVE SUPPLY SHORTAGES IN
THE VALLEY AGAIN YOU KNOW
FAMILIAR PATTERN WE THINK THAT
10% OF THE STATE'S POPULATION.
HALF OF THE THE SYSTEMS THAT ARE
IN TROUBLE AND THEN ALMOST 80%
OF THE WELLS REPORTED DRY AND WE
KNOW THIS IS AN UNDER REPORT
BECAUSE IT WAS A JUST A
VOLUNTARY THING WASN'T COLLECTED
EVERYWHERE.
UP OVER 80% IN THE VALLEY SO
THIS IS A THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT'S GOING TO BE.
PERSISTENT IN FUTURE DROUGHTS
AND ALSO SOMETHING TO THINK
ABOUT AND THE THE THE JEEP THE
GROUNDWATER SENSIBILITY AGENCIES
WILL HAVE TO THINK ABOUT AS THE
IMPLEMENT A GLIDE PATH.
BECAUSE IF THEY'RE GONNA ALLOW
SOME CONTINUED OVERDRAFT THEY'VE
GOT TO BE ABLE TO MITIGATE THAT.
SO HERE'S HERE THE TOP
PRIORITIES AND SARGE IS GOING TO
BE IS IS IS IN THE TRENCHES ON
THIS -- IT IN IT IN THE VALLEY
AND ELSEWHERE IN THE STATE IS
GOING TO HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
THOUGHTS TO SHARE BUT THESE ARE
KIND OF SOME TOP PRIORITIES.
YOU SEE THAT I'VE GOT LITTLE RED
STARS THERE ON ALL OF THEM
BECAUSE THE STATE HAS TO JUST
PLAY A MAJOR ROLE RECOGNIZING
THAT.
A LOT OF THE SOLUTIONS ARE GONNA
HAVE TO INVOLVE VARIOUS LOCAL
PLAYERS URBAN WATER SYSTEMS YOUR
CATION DISTRICTS COUNTIES AND SO
ON BUT THE STATE REALLY NEEDS TO
PROVIDE SOME LEADERSHIP HERE --
THERE IT WOULD AND WE HAVE TO
THINK ABOUT THIS AS TECHNICAL
MANAGERIAL AND FINANCIAL SO THE
INSURER FINDING IS AN A IS A
NECESSARY BUT NOT SUFFICIENT.
PIECE OF THIS PUZZLE IT'S ALSO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE HOW WE'RE
GONNA DO THEY DO THIS ON THE
GROUND.
AND GETTING AN ACTION PLAN --
THIRD AREA I'M GONNA TOUCH ON IS
THIS LONG TERM WRONG GROUND
WATER QUALITY CHALLENGES --
WHICH IS YOU KNOW ESPECIALLY AN
ISSUE FOR FOR AGRICULTURAL
MANAGEMENT.
OF NITRATE BEING BEING A KEY ONE
THERE IS A A A A A NEW
REGULATORY PROGRAM NOW EVEN OVER
THE LAST DECADE OR SO WE'VE BEEN.
WORKING TO TO TO REGULATE
GROUNDWATER CALIFORNIA'S BEEN A
LEADER ON THIS RELATIVE TO MANY
OTHER STATES -- AND SO THAT IS
THAT THERE ARE VARIOUS PROGRAMS
TO ROUTE TO BOTH FOR DAIRIES AND
FOR YOUR GATED LANDS TO LOOK AT
AT NITROGEN AS WELL AS AS WELL
AS AT FAULT -- IF THERE'S BEEN
PROGRESS MADE IN IN SOME WAYS
BUT THIS IS A HARD AND IT'S
ESPECIALLY HARD FOR DAIRIES
WHICH IS WHAT I'M HIGHLIGHTING
FOR YOU HERE -- THERE'S JUST ALL
TOO MUCH MINORE RELATIVE TO THE
CROP LAND THAT DAIRIES HAVE
AVAILABLE MENORES HARD TO MANAGE.
EFFICIENTLY AND AND THERE'S NOW
RECOGNITION THAT SOME OF THAT
WOOD NOR HAS TO BE ABLE TO BE
EXPORTED OFFER THE DAIRIES AND
TRANSFORM TO BE USED IN SOME
OTHER WAY SO.
JUST AS A KIND OF INDICATOR OF
THAT THE MAP A SHOWS YOU THE
DERRY CROPLAND THOSE THOSE RED
DOTS THERE.
AND THAT ALMOST MAPS YOU KNOW
ONE FOR ONE WITH THE THE REAL
HOT SPOTS FOR NITROGEN LOADING
YOU CAN SEE THE THE THE BRIGHT
RED AND ORANGE THERE -- ABOUT 6%
OF CROPLAND IS DERRY CROPLAND
AND ALMOST 90% OF THE HOT THE
HOTTEST HOT SPOTS IN NITROGEN
LOADING ARE ARE ON THOSE
CROPLANDS.
SAYS IT'S A CHALLENGE THAT THIS
THE SECTORS RECOGNIZING AND AND
YOU KNOW TRUCK TRYING TO GRAPPLE
WITH AT THIS POINT.
ON THE OTHER ISSUE IS SOLVED AND
THEN THIS WHERE'S MY TRADE IS
REALLY AN ISSUE FOR DRINKING
WATER QUALITY.
SALT IS REALLY AN ISSUE FOR AG
PRODUCTIVITY -- MAP SHOWS YOU
KIND OF THE SHALLOW GROUNDWATER
GROUNDWATER SALINITY AND THE OF
THE WEST SIDE OF THE VALLEY HAS
SOME HAS LONG TERMS ASSAULT
ISSUES.
THAT BAR CHART SHOWS YOU WHICH
CROP START TO DECLINE YIELD THAT
I WHICH LEVEL OF SALINITY AND A
LOT OF THE HIGHER VALUE -- CROPS
THAT ARE MOST QUICKLY AFFECTED
BY SALINITY SO THIS IS A AN
ONGOING CHALLENGE FOR
AGRICULTURE AND THAT THE
SOLUTIONS ARE THE TECHNICAL
SOLUTIONS ARE EXPENSIVE -- USE
SOME OF THE BIG DE SALLE EFFORTS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT ARE
EXPENSIVE RELATIVE TO WHAT
FARMERS CAN AFFORD SO THIS IS AN
ISSUE. FOR YOU WHERE FARMERS ARE
OFTEN NOW REALLY USING ECONOMIC
MANAGEMENT.
ALL RATHER THAN SORT OF THE THE
THE BIG INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS BECAUSE THAT'S KIND
OF WHAT'S MOST COST EFFECTIVE IN
ONE OF THE ONE OF THE TOOLS AS
CROP SHIFTING THEIR OTHER THINGS
YOU CAN DO ON THE FARM TO MANAGE
AS BUT ALSO OVER TIME.
SOME LAND IT COMES OUT OF
PRODUCTION OF BECAUSE ASSAULTS
ALREADY ABOUT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRES OF COME OUT OF
PRODUCTION OVER TIME.
AND THERE'S ANOTHER ESTIMATED I
THINK ONE POINT. FIVE MILLION
ACRES THAT ARE BETTER SALT
IMPACTED SO SOMETHING TO THINK
ABOUT IN THE CONTEXT OF IT SOME
LAND IT'S GOING TO BE COMING OUT
OF PRODUCTION FOR WATER SUPPLY.
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO COORDINATE
THAT WITH WITH THE SALT
MANAGEMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
WATER CAN BE FLEXIBLY MOVED. TO
THE MOST PRODUCTIVE LANDS --
THEN AT ONE THING ALSO FLAG FOR
YOU AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
THOMAS CAN CAN AMONG OTHER
THINGS THE THOMAS CAN TALK A LOT
MORE ABOUT IS.
HOW TO MANAGE QUALITY AND
QUANTITY TOGETHER WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT GROUNDWATER RECHARGE WHICH
IS THE SIZE YOU KNOW THE BIG ONE
OF THE BIG TOOLS FOR THE VALLEY
IN TERMS OF A COST EFFECTIVE?
OPTION FOR EXPANDING SUPPLY.
ARM PUTTING RECHARGE ON CROP
LAND IS A PRETTY GOOD OPTION
FROM A COST PERSPECTIVE THERE'S
A LOT OF CROP LAND IN THE VALLEY
THAT HAS SUITABLE SOILS.
THE FOLKS ARE EXPERIMENTING WITH
THIS AND YOU KNOW FARMERS LIKE
DON CAMERON FROM THE STATE BOARD
OF FOOD A NAGGING OTHERS OF AN
EXPERIMENT WITH THOSE FOLKS THAT
YOU YOU SEE DAVIS I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS I'M A RESEARCH
PERSPECTIVE.
THE ONE OF THE BIG CHALLENGES
BEYOND JUST KIND OF ARE YOU
LEGALLY ENTITLED TO GET THE
WATER AND ALL OF THOSE SORT OF
INSTITUTIONAL THINGS.
IS MAKING SURE THAT YOU'RE NOT.
IMPAIRING WATER QUALITY IN WAYS
THAT RUN AFOUL OF REGULATIONS
WHILE YOU'RE DOING THIS BECAUSE
IF YOU PUT A LOT OF WATER ON THE
SOILS.
YOU CAN END UP PUSHING NITROGEN
DOWN INTO THE INTO THE WATER
TABLE AND WHAT THIS CROP WE'LL
SHOWS YOU HERE IS THAT.
OF ALL THE SUITABLE SOILS IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY IT'S ABOUT
HALF A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN HALF
OF ALL THE YEAR GET A CROP LAND.
IS SUITABLE -- ONLY THAT DARK
BLUE PORTION IS KIND OF
CONSIDERED CLEAN CROPS THAT.
WERE YOU WOULDN'T AUTOMATICALLY
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THAT ISSUE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER CROPS
THAT ARE POTENTIALLY SUITABLE
CAN TOLERATE OF THE THE RECHARGE
BUT WERE YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
THE NITROGEN MANAGEMENT AND
THAT'S THAT WHOLE HALF THEIR OF
OF THE GREEN THE GREEN THERE
WITH ALMONDS AND PISTACHIOS --
AT OTHER TREE CROPS AND SO ON SO
SOMETHING TO SOMETHING TO THINK
ABOUT WHERE THE STATE IS GOING
TO NEED TO HELP.
PROVIDE SOME CLARITY ON THE
REGULATORY SIDE ARM AND IN FACT
THERE IS YOUR THESE ARE ARE ARE
ARE SORT OF PRIORITIES A LOT
IT'S HAS TO HAPPEN.
AGAIN BY A LOCAL AND REGIONAL
ACTORS BUT THE STATE CAN BE
REALLY.
IMPORTANT IN HELPING PROVIDE
GUIDANCE AND SOME REGULATORY
FLEXIBILITY ON MANAGING THE LONG
TERM NITROGEN SALT.
ESPECIALLY IN THE CONTEXT OF
THINKING ABOUT SOMETHING LIKE
RECHARGE AND THE THE NEW SALT
AND NITRATE CONTROL PROGRAM THAT
THE REGIONAL BOARD HAS ADOPTED
AND THAT IS STILL -- IS PENDING
APPROVAL BY THE STATE WATER
BOARD.
HAS SOME OF THAT FLEXIBILITY
BUILT IN ARM IN A WAY THAT KIND
OF INSURERS THAT.
AS LONG AS FOLKS ARE ADDRESSING
SAFE DRINKING WATER PROBLEMS
URGENTLY -- THERE THEY PROVIDE
SOME FLEXIBILITY FOR LONGER TERM
LONGER TERM SOLUTIONS ON ON THE
AG SIDE WHICH WOULD WHICH WHICH
WE THINK IS THE IT IS IS A SMART
APPROACH.
SO LAST ONE THIS IS THIS IDEA OF
KIND OF I DON'T KNOW I SOMETIMES
CALLED MAKING LEMONADE OUT OF
LEMONS -- WHICH IS YOU KNOW THE
IDEA THAT SOME LAND IS LIKELY TO
BE COMING OUT OF PRODUCTION.
HOW TO MANAGE THAT IN WAYS THEY
GET VALUE FOR THE VALLEY AS
OPPOSED TO JUST CAUSING NEGATIVE
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES?
OF WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT THE
THERE'S NOT ANY WHERE NEAR THE
KIND OF THINKING OR PLANNING
THIS AWARENESS IS BEGINNING TO
BE AWARENESS OF THIS ISSUE.
BUT NOT NOT THE THOSE KIND OF
SERIOUS PLANNING THAT'S NEEDED
TO THINK ABOUT.
HOW TO HOW TO AVOID A KIND OF
FARM BY FARM YOU KNOW POSTAGE
STAMP APPROACH TO THIS THAT
DOESN'T GET VALUE FROM THE LANDS
AND THIS PIE CHART?
THIS DOUGHNUT JUST GIVES YOU A
SENSE OF THAT HERE I'M LOOKING
AT THE ARE ARE SORT OF LOW BALL
ESTIMATE OF LAND COMING OUT OF
PRODUCTION THIS IS IN THE IN THE
SORT OF OPTIMAL APPROACH WHERE
YOU GET NEW SUPPLIES SO IT'S A
LITTLE BIT OVER.
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES THAT
WOULD COME OUT OF PRODUCTION
OVER OVER TIME.
AND THE THE SMALLER LITTLE
SLICES OF THAT DOUGHNUT THOSE
ARE KIND OF THE THE AMOUNT OF
LAND THAT ARE YOU KNOW UNDER
EXISTING PLANNING PROCESS THESE.
UP COULD LIKELY FIT INTO SOME
KIND OF SPECIFIC ACTIVITY THAT
INCLUDES THERE'S A RECOVERY PLAN
FOR THE SAN JOAQUIN DESERT WHICH
WOULD BE ABOUT EIGHTY THOUSAND
ACRES.
MAYBE ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES
OF SOLAR -- IN THE COCKPIT OF
ADDITIONAL SOLAR BEYOND WHAT'S
BEEN DONE -- AND THEN A MAYBE
TWENTY THOUSAND EACH OF RIPARIAN
QUARTERS AND OR EXPANDING
REPAIRING QUARTERS AND AND SOME
MORE IN INTERMENT WETLANDS OF
THE TYPE THAT YOU SEE IN THE
CURRENT WATER BANK.
WHICH IS A GROUND WATER BANK
THAT THAT IS IT INTERMITTENTLY
ALSO HOT REVERT BIRD HABITAT SO
THIS WHOLE BIG TWO THIRDS OF THE
OF THIS DONATH THE YEP THE
GOLDEN PART.
IS JUST IT'S NOT SPECIFIC LAND
THAT WE'RE SHOWING HERE SO MUCH
AS JUST THE IDEA THAT THERE'S
MORE THAN FITS IN THOSE IN THOSE
CATEGORIES SO FAR.
WE THINK THAT THERE IS POTENTIAL
TO STEWART ALL OF THESE LANDS IN
BENEFICIAL WAYS AND SOME OF THAT
CAN BE ROTATIONAL FOLLOWING
WHERE YOU'RE IMPROVING SOIL
HEALTH.
GETTING SOME BENEFITS IN TERMS
OF EVEN IMPROVING THE ABILITY TO
RETAIN MOISTURE BUT ALSO STORING
CARBON IN THE MEAN TIME BUT THEN
PROBABLY YOU KNOW USING SOME OF
THESE LANDS IN IN IN OTHER WAYS.
TO TO KIND OF STACKED STACKED
BENEFITS -- FOR BRINGING IN
REVENUES FOR FOR GROWERS FOR
LANDOWNERS BUT ALSO GETTING SOME
YOU KNOW PUBLIC HEALTH AND
RECREATIONAL AND FLOOD CONTROL --
VARIOUS OTHER KINDS OF BENEFITS
FOR THE REGION.
SO A PRIORITIES FOR THIS -- GOT
TO START WITH SOME BROAD BASED
PLANNING.
IMPLEMENTING FLEXIBLE REGULATORY
APPROACHES AGAIN THAT THING THE
FLEXIBILITY PROVIDING FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES AND BOOSTING
TECHNICAL SUPPORT R. D. U. C.
GOT I'VE GOT STARS ON ALL BUT
THE TOP ONE THAT'S NOT BECAUSE
THE STATE.
DOESN'T HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY
THERE JUST THE STATE OBVIOUSLY
CAN'T TAKE A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN
LAND USE PLANNING IN IN THIS IS
THAT'S A THAT'S A LOCAL AND
REGIONAL THING.
BUT WE THINK ACTUALLY THE STATE
CAN BE IMPORTANT AS A SUPPORTER
OF OF THAT.
SO JUST TO WRAP UP WITH A FEW
THOUGHTS ON YOU KNOW THIS IS A
HUGE AGENDA AND IT'S NOT AN
OVERNIGHT AGENDA OF FOR ALL OF
THE THINGS I'VE TALKED ABOUT
WHERE WHERE CAN YOU BE MOST
HELPFUL.
IN THE NEAR TERM THE FIRST ONE
IS SAFE DRINKING WATER AND I
THINK IT'S NOT JUST THE FUNDING
IT'S ALSO MAKING SURE THERE IS A
A COMPREHENSIVE ROBUST FRAMEWORK
FOR ADDRESSING BOTH THE THE
QUALITY AND THE SUPPLY.
ISSUES.
THE SECOND IS SUPPORTING THE
REGION'S TRANSITION TO GROUND
WATER SUSTAINABILITY AND THIS IS
THINKING ABOUT IN THE FIRST FIVE
YEARS OF THESE PLANS PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO BE JUST.
REALLY GEARING UP ARM HOW TO
SUPPORT THAT SO.
NUMBER ONE IS THE STATE GETTING
ITS OWN REGULATORY.
SILOS A LITTLE BIT ON THE SIDE
LOAD SO THAT THERE CAN BE
SUPPORT YOU KNOW FOR FOR WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE ACROSS THESE
DIFFERENT CHALLENGE AREAS.
THE SECOND IS HELPING TO ASSESS
SMART INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS
AND THEN SUPPORTING PILOTS ON
THE GROUND AND I THINK YOU KNOW
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES CAN BE
REALLY HELPFUL IN THAT KIND OF
THING -- AS WELL AS TECHNICAL
SUPPORT OUR INDIE.
AND SUPPORTING PLANNING.
AND THAT'S ALL THAT'S ALL I HAVE
TO CONTRIBUTE TO YOU AND WE'LL
LEAVE YOU WITH SOME NICE A NICE
PHOTOS AND WE CAN.
MOVE ON TO THANK YOU DOCTOR THE
REST ALL RIGHT WILL WANT -- TO
THOMAS HARDER.
YOU WANT ME TO GO NEXT.
WELL MY FOCUS IS GOING TO BE ON
THE DRINKING WATER PIECE OKAY --
YOUR SERGEANT GREEN YES SIR --
INTERIM DIRECTOR FRESNO STATE
CENTER FOR IRRIGATION TECHNOLOGY
AND I'M ALSO THE ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR FOR THE WATER RESOURCES
IN POLICY INITIATIVES WHICH IS
HELD OUT OF THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE FOR ALL TWENTY THREE
CAMPUSES.
AND ONE OF THE PROJECTS THAT I'M
WORKING ON THROUGH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE -- PROGRAM
AT WPI IS TO HANDHOLD DAX
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF GETTING --
APPLICATIONS TO THE SYSTEM FOR A
FINANCING SO -- FOR EXAMPLE I'M
WORKING WITH -- A SMALL RURAL
SCHOOL IN THE MANTI CARE AREA AS
WELL AS THE CITY PORTOLA -- AND
PICKING UP A COUPLE MORE IN THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS -- THERE'S A
COUPLE PROBLEMS WITH THAT NOT
ALL COMMENT ON THAT A LITTLE
LATER BUT I REALLY WANTED TO
HELP YOU WITH IS IS THE NOTION
THAT WE REALLY CAN FOCUS ON
DEALING WITH SOME OF THE
DRINKING WATER ISSUES ESPECIALLY.
FOR THE SMALL COMMUNITIES THAT
WERE NOTED IN OUR REPORT ON THE
PP I SEE -- IN THE SOME LOOKING
VALLEY ALL OF THE SYSTEMS THAT
ARE NON COMPLIANT -- UP A YOU
SHOULD ALSO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FORTY
INDEPENDENT SCHOOLS THAT HAVE
THEIR OWN DRINKING WATER SYSTEM.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T KNOW YET HOW
MANY ARE NOT COMPLIANT WITH THE
DRINKING WATER STANDARDS BUT
CLEARLY -- THAT'S A SPECIAL
PROJECT THAT WE'D LIKE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT AT TO HELP THEM OUT TO
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE
SUSTAINABILITY -- AT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I THINK WE WANT TO
FOCUS ON IS THE MAKING SURE THAT
THE FUNDING THAT WE DO GIVE TO
THE SMALL COMMUNITIES.
HAS A PRIORITY AND WHAT I'M
RECOMMENDING IS IS THAT WE DO
NEED TO PERHAPS PRIORITIZE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER AS ONE OF THE
FIRST AREAS THAT WE NEED TO
FINANCE AND PERHAPS EVEN FAST
TRACK PROCESS. TO GET THAT GOING
SO WHERE ARE THEY WHAT ARE THEY
DOING -- WE NEED TO REPLACE SOME
OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE OF THIS IN
CALIFORNIA -- ESPECIALLY WHERE
IT'S AT ITS END OF ITS USABLE
LIFE AND BUT THAT'S ALSO LINKED
TO DRINKING WATER SO YOUR SEEN
THE PHOTOGRAPHS OF THE PIPE THAT
BLEW UP ON SUNSET BOULEVARD
RIGHT -- THE I DID PART OF UCLA
OF SO THERE'S SOME OLD STUFF IN
THE GROUND SO WE THINK THAT'S
IMPORTANT.
I THINK IF THERE IS A WATER
STORAGE INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT
DESIGNED WITH ENVIRONMENTAL
PURPOSES WAS ALREADY MENTIONED
EARLIER BY.
MS EHLERS THAT WE NEED TO
SUPPORT THE INSTITUTIONS AND THE
PRACTICES THAT DELIVER
QUANTIFIABLE RESULTS FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT THAT'S OUTCOME BASED
THAT SHE MENTIONED.
SO -- TO TALK A LITTLE BIT THEN
ABOUT -- SOME OF THIS OTHER
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES THAT WERE
WORKING ON AND I THINK WE NEED
TO ALSO REMEMBER THAT A LOT OF
MORE PRIVATE WHETHER IT'S THE
MOBILE HOME PARKS IN SOME CASES
CAMPGROUNDS.
THOSE ARE ALL WHAT THEY CALL NON
TRANSIENT NON COMMUNITY WATER
SYSTEMS IN WATER SPEAK IN THE
DRINKING WATER WORLD.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY
TO TRY AND GET OUR ARMS AROUND
WHO THEY ARE WHERE THEY ARE AND
WHAT KIND OF INSTITUTIONAL
CHANGES WE MIGHT NEED TO MAKE TO
HELP THEM OUT. ONE EXAMPLE IS IT
WITH ANOTHER RECENT CONTRACT
WE'RE WORKING ON IS THE CITY OF
FRESNO IS GOING TO ACT AS A
FOCAL POINT FOR HOOKING UP.
SATELLITE SYSTEMS COMMUNITIES
AROUND THE CITY OF FRESNO TO SEE
WHAT ARE THE OPPORTUNITIES WHAT
ARE THE CHALLENGES AND WHAT ARE
THE COSTS GOING TO BE.
SO IT'S KIND OF A OF A PATTERN
OR A PRECEDENT SETTING PROCESS
THAT WERE INVOLVED IN IT IS ONCE
AGAIN THROUGH THE W. R..
T. I. PROCESS IN ADDITION THE
CAMPUS AT FRESNO STATE IS ITS
OWN WATER SYSTEM NOT A LOT OF
PEOPLE KNOW THAT WE DELIVER.
BOTH ARE DRINKING WATER AND
WATER TO OUR FARM -- IN WHAT
PART OF THE GSA AND AND NOW
WE'VE MADE A COMMITMENT NOT ONLY
TO DO RESEARCH ON RECHARGE
BENEFITS BUT ALSO A TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR OF
CAMPUS IN KIND STAFF SERVICES.
TO HELP OUR GSA WITH SOME OF THE
ISSUES SO THE KIND OF
PARTNERSHIPS I THINK ARE THE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT WE NEED TO
DO MORE OF ONE OF THE BIG THINGS
THAT -- I'M INVESTED IN IS ALSO
THE NOTION THAT WAS MENTIONED BY --
MS EHLERS A GNAT IS MEASUREMENT
AND MONITORING -- WE NEED TO
MORE INVESTMENTS IN IN THAT TYPE
OF ACTIVITY -- IT IN IN A GOOD
SPECIFIC EXAMPLE THAT I HAVE
JUST LAST WEEK.
WE HAVE AT THE FRESNO STATE
CAMPUS AN INCUBATOR WERE FUNDED
BY THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION TO DO WATER AND
ENERGY TECHNOLOGY INCUBATION.
AT A COMPANY HAS ARRIVED AND
WE'RE GOING TO BRING THEM TO OUR
PROCESS THAT CAN INSTANTANEOUSLY
TEST FOR E. COLI.
THESE THE ONE NUMBER ONE ANY
INDICATOR OF BACTERIAL COMIC
CONTAMINATION IN WATER USUALLY
YOU HAVE TO SEND IT TO A
LABORATORY TAKES TWENTY FOUR
HOURS FORTY EIGHT HOURS BEFORE
YOU GET RESULTS THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
YOU CAN TEST IT INSTANTANEOUSLY
AND THIS THING WORKS AND IT'S A
CHIP. TO CHIP IN A HAND HELD
DEVICE.
SO WE THINK THAT.
AN INVESTMENT IS ALSO PART OF
THE SOLUTION TO SOME OF THE
WATER QUALITY PROBLEMS AND
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE FACING US IN
CALIFORNIA -- ALONG. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I BELIEVE THAT WE
NEED TO DO IS THAT WE WE NEED
BETTER INTEGRATION IT'S SOME OF
OUR AGENCIES AS WELL -- ONE OF
THE IDEAS IS THAT.
WE DO NOT HAVE ACTUAL TECHNICAL
EXPERTS IN EITHER OF THE WATER
BOARD OR DEPARTMENT WATER
RESOURCES THAT ARE WHITE HAT
PEOPLE THAT CAN ASSIST AND
REVIEW AND LOOK AT WHETHER OR
NOT -- THE PROPOSAL FOR
DEVELOPING A CYST SOLUTION TO A
SYSTEM IS THE RIGHT.
ONE AND THE EXAMPLE I POINT TO
AN A TALKED ABOUT IN NUMEROUS
PLACES YOU PROBABLY HEARD ABOUT.
IS LYNN THERE.
WHEN THERE IS A SMALL COMMUNITY
IN WESTERN FRESNO COUNTY THAT
HAD A MULTI MILLION DOLLAR
ARSENIC PLANT BUILT AND IT'S
SITTING IDLE?
BECAUSE THE CITY -- THE GIGA
COMMUNITY RESIDENTS COULD NOT
AFFORD.
AND IT SHOULD HAVE BEEN STOPPED
IF WE HAD THE RIGHT ADVICE IN
THE FIRST PLACE TO PLANT TO
REMOVE ARSENIC NOT TO PUT A IT'S
TO REMOVE OUR SHOT IT. TO GET
I'M JUST TRYING TO GET YOU TO
GET A LITTLE MORE YEAH IT WAS TO
REMOVE OUR STICK AT AND IT AND
IT'S IT'S BEEN A FAILURE.
SO WE NEED SOME WHITE HAD PEOPLE
IN SOME OF THE AGENCIES THAT CAN
ACTUALLY GUIDE THE DEVELOPMENT
OF PROPER PROJECTS RATHER THAN
JUST REGULATED AND RIGHT WE HAVE --
THE DIVISION A DRINK OF WATER
CANNOT ADVISE PEOPLE ON WHAT TO
USE -- I THINK THAT THE REAL BIG
AREA THOUGH IS THE INSTITUTIONAL
ASPECT AND WHAT I'M SUGGESTING
IS.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A KIND OF A
STRESS TEST.
AND THAT STRESS TEST IS --
WHETHER OR NOT A SYSTEM HAS A
NUMBER OF COMPLIMENTS NUMBER ONE
IS DO THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
REPELLENTS.
NUMBER TWO CAN THEY AFFORD
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE COSTS
NUMBER.
THREE CAN THEY RETAIN QUALIFIED
OPERATORS NUMBER FOUR TWO THEY
HAVE ASSET MANAGEMENT AND
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENT PLANS.
AND NUMBER FIVE IS CAN INVEST IN
A SINKING FUND.
ANY SMALL ORGANIZATION THEY
CANNOT BEAT THAT STRESS TEST AND
IT'S DIFFICULT IT'S DIFFICULT
EVEN FOR SOME LARGER SINKING
FUND THAT'S A BANK ACCOUNT THAT
REPLACES.
MONEY FOR THE THINGS THAT YOU
KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
REPLACE ADDED AT THE END OF IT
USABLE LIFE.
OKAY SO IT'S A SMALL AMOUNT OF
MONEY EVERY YEAR BUT IT BUILDS
UP OVER TIME SO THAT WHEN
SOMETHING IS READY TO BE
REPLACED AT TWENTY FIVE YEARS
YOU HAVE THE MONEY.
IT'S A SUSTAINABILITY FACTOR.
SO I THINK THOSE REQUIREMENTS
WILL FORCE IS TO LOOK AT
ALTERNATE INSTITUTIONAL
ARRANGEMENTS AND I KNOW THAT A
LOT OF SMALL SYSTEMS AND ENJOY
LOCAL CONTROL.
BUT I THINK SOME OF THE MORE
SUCCESSFUL ONES HAVE DONE THINGS
LIKE JOINT POWERS AGREEMENT
WHERE THEY STILL HAVE THEIR OWN
BOARD BUT ON COMMON ISSUES.
OF A LARGE EXPANSE OR PLANNING
OR RETAINING QUALIFIED PEOPLE
YOU CAN GET THOSE ORGANIZATIONS
TO WORK TOGETHER IN THE CASE OF
THE PRIVATE SIDE.
IT'S PROBABLY ASSOCIATIONS OF
SOME TYPE SO I THINK WE HAVE TO
FIND A LOGICAL MANAGEMENT
PROCESSES FOR VARIOUS AREAS --
WHO'S IN THOSE AREAS AND ANALYZE
THEM AND THEN GET THEM TO JOIN
TOGETHER IN A PROCESS THAT WORKS
FOR ALL OF US -- AN EXAMPLE THAT
I'VE I'VE WORKED WITH ALREADY
WAS -- CURSED HAS A HIGH SCHOOL
YOU SOMEBODY HIGH SCHOOL IT
JOINED UP WITH HILL VIEW WATER
DISTRICT RECENTLY SO IT'S NO
LONGER ITS OWN WATER SUPPLIER.
SIMILARLY THE ONE THAT I WORKED
ON IN MANTI KANAL GARDEN SCHOOL --
STILL FINISHING THE FAST PROCESS
WITH THEM THEY'VE JOINED THE
STADIUM ANTICA SO WE'VE GOT SOME
EXAMPLES ARE WORKING ON THIS
ALREADY -- AND SO WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE THIS PROCESS
FORWARD LASTLY I HAVE TO ADMIT
AND SAY WHAT I ALLUDED TO
EARLIER.
IS THAT CONTRACTS AND
DISBURSEMENT ARE STILL TAKING
TOO LONG.
IT'S A DIFFICULT PROCESS TO GET
THROUGH AND ON EVEN AN
ORGANIZATION LIKE OURS THE WATER
RESOURCES POLICIES TO STRUGGLES
TO GET CONTRACTS THROUGH SO THAT
WE CAN ASSIST WITH GETTING SOME
OF THESE SMALL SYSTEMS THROUGH
THE PROCESS SO.
THAT HAS TO BE LOOKED AT I THINK
EXTERNALLY AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
SO MY NAME IS THOMAS HARDER I'M
THE ARMORED M. HAGEN AND DOUBT
TEAR FOR WATER MANAGEMENT POLICY
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AND AND DAVIS I'M A PROFESSOR
AND I'M ALSO.
RUNNING THE CARPET OF EXTENSION
PROGRAM ON GROUNDWATER AND
AGRICULTURE AND IN THAT FUNCTION
I'M ON THE BOARD FOR THE GROUND
WATER RESOURCE ASSOCIATION AND
WHAT EDUCATION FOUNDATION AND
STAFF MET A COUPLE OF YOUR ARM
ON THAT OCCASION -- I'M HERE
MOSTLY TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS WE'VE BEEN I'VE BEEN
ENGAGED IN SORT OF THE TECHNICAL
BEATS OF A LOT OF THIS REPORT.
THROUGH MY COMPANY EXTENSION
PROGRAM I WORK WITH THE GET IN
LINE SORT OF TORY PROGRAMME
COALITIONS WITH THE REGIONAL
WATER BOARDS AND THE STATE WATER
BOARD PROVIDING TECHNICAL ADVICE
ON IRRIGATED LAND SORT OF HEART
PROGRAM.
ON A DAIRY ORDER INTO CENTRAL
VALLEY I'M ALSO VERY ENGAGED IN
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE GROUND
WATER SUSTAINABILITY PLANS WHERE
ARE WORSE SPECIFICALLY ENGAGED
IN AN ORDER PART OF THE STATE
WITH THIS YOU COUNTY BUT I ALSO
DO.
QUITE A BIT OF OUTREACH AND AND
AND EXTENSION IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY CENTRAL COAST IN AN ORDER
AND NORTHERN CALIFORNIA COUNTIES.
ON THAT V. WERE HERE SEVEN YEARS
AGO 2% TO YOU TO THE LEGISLATURE
THE REPORT.
ON NITRATE IN A JULY LIKE BASIN
AND AND THE SALINAS VALLEY THAT
KICK MUCH OF THIS OFF THAT WAS
ON REQUEST FROM THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THROUGH THE STATE WATER
RESUSCITATED BOARD.
ARM AND SO I'M HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ON BOTH THE GROUND
WATER SUPPLY SIDE AND AND
NITROGEN SALT QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
THE QUESTIONS WERE AFTER.
THIS SHOW -- ELLEN HANNEKE YES --
SO A LOT OF WHAT YOU STRESSED IS
GETTING MONEY.
ARE FOR THE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT NETWORK CURRENTLY
TRYING TO GO THROUGH A PROCESS
TO GET MONEY.
FOR A SAFE DRINKING WATER.
WE ALL AGREE THERE SHOULD BE
MONEY -- QUESTION OF WHO YOU
TAXED GET AT WHAT SORT OF
RESOURCES ARE NEEDED TO HELP
WITH THE GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT.
SO.
IT IS KIND OF YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THERE AS AS THE SELLERS WAS
SAYING YOU KNOW THERE THERE ARE.
A RANGE OF DIFFERENT FUNDING
SOURCES THAT WHAT ONE CAN USE
AND YOU KNOW THERE'S NOT A HARD
AND FAST RULE ON WHICH IS RIGHT
FOR FOR WHICH BUT I'LL GIVE YOU
MY PHILOSOPHY ABOUT THIS --
WHICH IS THAT -- A LOT OF IS
THAT WHAT OUR USERS CURRENTLY
PAY.
FOR THE MAJORITY OF OF THE
INVESTMENTS AND THE THE
OPERATIONS AND MANAGEMENT FOR
FOR WATER USE -- AND THE WAY
WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT GROUND
WATER SUSTAINABILITY AND KIND OF
ENDING OVERDRAFT WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT IT FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF OF ASSUMING THAT
FARMERS AND AND AND CITIES WHAT
WILL WILL CONTINUE.
TO AS THEY HAVE ALREADY TO TO
PAY FOR FOR THEIR OR THEIR WATER
SUPPLIES -- AND THE GSA'S AROUND
OR STAND ABILITY AGENCIES DO
HAVE.
THE AUTHORITY THE THE
LEGISLATION GRIP -- LEGISLATION
GRANTED THEM THE AUTHORITY TO TO
RAISE.
FEES FOR INVESTMENTS I THINK YOU
KNOW AT THIS POINT MANY OF THEM
HAVE.
HAVE BEEN KIND OF FIGURING OUT --
THERE IN IT IN EARLY DAYS ON
THAT BECAUSE THEY'RE STILL ALSO
FIGURE OUT WHAT ARE THEIR
PROJECTS THAT THEY WANT TO
INVEST IN BUT THERE ARE OPTIONS
THAT INCLUDE.
ASSESSMENTS OF THE LAND WHICH IS
HOW SOME IRRIGATION DISTRICTS
ALSO -- RUN YOU KNOW COLLECT
COLLECT THEIR REVENUES NOW ON
BUT THERE'S ALSO AN OPTION OF
HAVING A GROUND WATER PUMPING
FEE THAT COULD BE USED TO TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THIS SO -- WENT IN
THE RESULTS THAT WE'RE SHOWING
YOU FOR FOR KIND OF THE QUARTER
OF SUPPLIES THAT COULD BE.
AFFORDABLY PAID -- FOR THAT'S
THAT'S ASSUMING USER USER PAYS
ON THAT AND IT'S IT TO MY MIND.
IN A WORLD OF LIMITED STATE
RESOURCES WHERE THE STATE CAN BE
MOST HELPFUL IS.
IN AND HELPING TO JUMPSTART.
INNOVATIONS KIND OF PROVIDING
INNOVATION FUNDS SORT OF
SUPPORTING PILOTS THAT WE CAN
KIND OF CAN HELP GET PEOPLE TO A
TRYING SOME NEW THINGS BUT THEN
ALSO FINDING THESE ORPHAN AREAS
WHERE.
THERE'S NOT.
THERE'S NOT THAT KIND OF IT'S
NOT AS EASY TO GET USER PAY AND
AND SO THINGS LIKE KIND OF HOW
TO MANAGE -- HOW TO MANAGE SOME
OF THE THE THE THE LANDS ON HOW
TO DO SOME OF THE PLANNING
PROCESS AND SO ON -- ARE AREAS
WHERE I WOULD.
I WOULD SORT OF SAYARE ARE KIND
OF ON THE TOP THE TOP LINE FOR
FOR STATE FUNDING OKAY -- I
WOULD SUGGEST IF YOU'VE GOT A
CONCRETE IDEAS WHICH YOU SEEM TO
HAVE THAT YOU -- SEND US WELL
LET'S SEE WE WE DO HAVE.
HERE IN OUR WATER IN THE FUTURE
OF THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
OVERVIEW AT SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY --
I'VE GOT THE OVERVIEW SECTION
HERE THE FIRST SIXTEEN PAGES --
IS THERE INFORMATION ON SPECIFIC
PROPOSALS IN THIS THAT WE WOULD
HAVE AN IDEA WHAT'S IN THE
LEGISLATION MIGHT BE NECESSARY.
THERE'S SOME THERE'S SOME.
IS SOME DIRECTIONS ON ON THINK
AREAS WHERE THE STATE CAN BE
VERY VERY HELPFUL WE HAVEN'T
GONE TO THE LEVEL OF VERY
SPECIFIC LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS
AND AND CERTAINLY NOT TO THE ON
THE ISSUE OF FUNDING WE COULD WE
COULD.
THERE ARE SOME OF THAT OUT LOOK.
NONE OF US.
LEGISLATORS ARE EXPERTS.
AND WHILE WE HAVE STAFF WHO ARE
MUCH MORE EXPERT THAN WE ARE --
IT WOULD REALLY HELP TO HAVE
SOME CONCRETE -- RECOMMENDATIONS
AND I WOULD SAY THAT. TO ALL
THREE OF YOU -- IF YOU COULD
GIVE US CONCRETE REPRESENTATION
WE NEED A LAW TO DO ARE WE NEED
APPROPRIATIONS.
FOR AND YOU COULD SEND THAT TO
MYSELF AND CHAIRED GARCIA -- AND
TO OUR COMMITTEE STAFF AND WE
CAN TAKE A LOOK AT IT FOR NEXT
YEAR AND THE YEAR AFTER AND SEE
WHAT WE CAN DO.
BUT THE KEY TO HELP US ROUTE
REALLY HELP TO GET DOWN TO VERY
CONCRETE PROPOSALS -- IT'S GREAT
TO HAVE THIS -- OVERVIEW.
BUT TO HAVE A CONCRETE PROPOSAL
REALLY HELPS GET OUR MINDS ON
THE ISSUE HOW MUCH WE CAN DO.
I DON'T KNOW BUT IT WOULD REALLY
HELP AND WE DEFINITELY DO WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THE AMOUNT OF LAND THAT HAS TO
BE FOLLOWED -- TO BE -- TO HELP.
GET SUSTAINABLE GROUND WATER
WHICH IS IN EVERYONE'S INTEREST
IN THE LONG RUN.
A TO MINIMIZE THAT'D BE GREAT
AND THAT YOU'RE SAYING REQUIRES
SOME STATE LEADERSHIP -- IT WAS --
WE HAD A REAL PROBLEM IN IT YEAH
I WOULD SAY THAT.
THIS GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
PLAN WAS PASSED BY PEOPLE FROM
CITIES.
NOT FROM THE AREAS WHO ARE
ACTUALLY BEING AFFECTED -- THEY
DO NOT WANT TO TAKE.
TAKE THE PAIN OF NOT -- OF
TRYING TO MANAGE THEIR GROUND
WATER.
IT WAS A REAL SHAME THAT IT WAS
DONE THAT WAY BUT THAT WAS THE
WAY IT WAS ONE.
AT ANY RATE -- WE REALLY DO NEED
CONCRETE PROPOSALS AND HOW WE
HELP MAKE THIS HAPPEN. ONE OF
THE CONCRETE PROPOSALS WE COULD
POSSIBLY RECOMMEND IS THERE IS.
A PROBLEM WE CALL CONNECTIVITY
AND THAT IS A LOT OF THE LEGACY
OLDER SYSTEMS THAT SERVE WATER.
ARE NOT NECESSARILY CONNECTED
WELL TO THE RECHARGE AREAS.
SO THERE'S SOME PLANNING STUDIES
THAT NEED TO BE DONE THAT COULD
HELP TO ACTUALLY DEVISE A PLAN
TO IMPROVE THOSE SITUATIONS.
SO THAT WAS ONE AREA PERHAPS AND
WE DID DISCUSS THAT IN IN THE
PROCESS.
THAT WE NEED.
TO DIG FURTHER INTO THAT ONE AND
ERIC SO AGAIN THE MORE CONCRETE
YOU CAN MAKE IT THE MORE HELPFUL
IT IS TO US THANK YOU.
I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I DO
WANT TO JUST UP AND KNOWLEDGE OF
THE DISCUSSIONS THAT -- MISS
GREENE.
PUTS FORWARD THAT IS A VERY REAL
TIME -- DISCUSSION POLICIES.
THE PRIOR HEARING YOU HEARD -- A
POTENTIAL PROPOSAL ON ENSURING
THAT THERE'S A STREAM OF FUNDING
GOING.
TO ADD THIS NEED ON A
REOCCURRING BASIS.
THERE ARE OTHER PROPOSALS OUT
THERE ATTEMPTING TO DO THE SAME
THING -- BECAUSE THERE'S OVER
MILLION PEOPLE THAT DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO CLEAN DRINKING WATER
AND YOU'VE POINTED OUT SOME OF
THE AREAS THAT ARE MOST
PREVALENT.
THERE ARE SOME AREAS THAT.
ARE NOT AS I GUESS POINTED OUT
IN THE MAPS BUT THAT STILL SEE
THOSE PROBLEMS -- AND SO WE WANT
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE
THIS YEAR WERE WORKING
COLLECTIVELY ON THAT.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS -- AROUND THOSE
ISSUES AND AGAIN WANT TO THANK
YOU -- FOR PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING US
SETTING UP UP MAYBE JUST ON ON
THAT SPECIFIC ISSUE -- I THINK.
WHO ARE ARE KIND OF COLLECTIVE
THINKING ON THIS IS THAT THE
FUNDING THE FUNDING IS AN
ESSENTIAL PIECE?
BUT RIGHT NOW THE WAY WERE
DRESSING.
THE TECHNICAL AND MANAGERIAL
SERVER SOLUTIONS ON THE GROUND
IS REALLY PIECEMEAL AND
FRAGMENTED ARM AND AND WE'RE NOT
GOING FAST ENOUGH I EITHER SO.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE COULD HELP IT
YOU. TO TO TO KIND OF OF
ENCOURAGE THE ADOPTION OF A OF A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH BY THE
STATE RIGHT NOW YOU'VE GOT THE
STATE WATER BOARD DOING A PIECE
YOU GOT THE PARTNER WATER
RESOURCES DOING A PIECE.
HERE THEY'RE THEY'RE SORT OF
INITIATIVES.
FROM DIFFERENT POCKETS OF OF OF
FINDING -- AND IT'S HARD TO SEE.
HOW IT ALL FITS TOGETHER IN IN A
ROBUST WAY AND AND YOU KNOW
MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S A?
A ROBUST UP PROCESS IS IS
SOMETHING I THINK WHERE THE THE
LEGISLATURE COULD BE REALLY
HELPFUL AND I THINK AND HAVE A
IF I CAN ADD TO THAT TOO NO I
THINK.
THIS PROGRAM THERE'S OTHER
PROGRAMS V. UC DAVIS AND THE
PRIMARY SOURCES OF STATION LAST
YEAR PUT OUT A WHITE PAPER ON
HOW.
TO SOME CONCRETE ACTIONS ON THE
ON THE ON THE MASHEK FOR
RECHARGED AND ADDING MORE
RESEARCH INTO GROUND WATER WITH
SOME OF OUR FLOODWATERS.
ARM THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES IS CURRENTLY WORKING
ON A RESEARCH AND DEVELOPMENT
PLAN.
FOR WHAT TO CALL FLOOD MARK
FLOOD MANAGE DOC FOR RECHARGE
AND I'M EXPECTING THERE TO BE A
FUND OF FUNDING PROPOSAL TO COME
OUT OF THAT.
IN A LARGE PICTURE BETWEEN THE
SYSTEM OF OUR MANAGEMENT ACT
IMPLEMENTATION AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING -- WITH IRINA LINE SECOND
TORY PROGRAMS ACROSS TO THE
VARIOUS REGIONS THERE ARE THERE
ARE CONTINUED NEEDS FOR THE
STATE TO BE ENGAGED IN DATA
COLLECTION AND MONITORING AND
SUPPORT.
SUPPORT THE LOCAL AGENCIES ARM
IN IN IN IN HELPING THEM WITH
COLLECTING DATA INTERPRETING
DOES DATA -- AND AND DOING THE
MONITORING AND MODELING THAT
WILL BE NEEDED AND SO I YOUR
COMMENT IS RIGHT ON TARGET AND
WILL BE.
PROVIDING SOME FEEDBACK AND WE'D
CERTAINLY LIKE TO KNOW WHAT HAS
TO BE DONE TO ENABLE THE A A
LARGE AREA -- TRADING -- WHAT'S
LEGAL WHAT ISN'T.
ETCETERA -- YOUR KNOWLEDGE ON
THIS WOULD HELP AND THEN -- ONCE
WE HAVE A CONCRETE POST SO WE
CAN WORK IT WITH THE STAFF HERE
THEY CAN DO MORE RESEARCH BUT
GETTING CONCRETE PROPOSALS WOULD
REALLY HELP US.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
I THINK WE HAVE -- TO
INDIVIDUALS AND WANTED TO SPEAK
ON AND PUBLIC COMMENTS AND SO
WILL OPEN THAT UP AT THIS TIME
[inaudible]
COME FORWARD.
STAY IN A GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON FURTHER ONLY HERE
ON BEHALF OF OUR MIDDLE DEFENSE
FUND FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE. FOR FOR HOSTING THIS
INFORMATIONAL SESSION -- NOT
ONLY THE VERY IN THE TIMELY
GIVEN THAT THERE ARE -- DRAFT
PLANS THAT ARE BEING DEVELOPED
AND THAT WILL BE ISSUED BY
JANUARY -- TWENTY TWENTY LARGELY
YOU KNOW THE THE THE WORK DONE
BY THE PPA C. HAS REALLY BAILEY
AT AN ISSUE THAT IS -- YOU KNOW
A LOT OF US HAVE BEEN HAVING
SOME AWKWARD CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS ABOUT
AS IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA WHAT
THIS ACTUALLY MEANS AND HANS
IT'S GOING TO DRIVE -- REALLY
BIG CHANGES IN THE AG SECTOR
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES THE
SENTENCING WALKING BALLY -- YOU
KNOW THE WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT
THERE CAN BE SOME REALLY GOOD
MECHANISMS AND INNOVATIVE
PROPOSALS BEING DRAFTED IN THOSE
PLANS BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT --
THE THE POTENTIAL RISK OF UP
240% OF LAND IN THE CENTER OF
THE MAILING OF FORCING --
FORCING IT TO BE FOLLOWED.
IT IS A REALLY BIG CHANGE ALL
TOGETHER AND AND REALLY WE
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND DOES
BELIEVE THAT THE STATE HAS A
ROLE TO PLAY AS HAS BEEN POINTED
OUT -- BY MISS NECK IN THE
PRESENTATION -- ON SOME OF THE
THE STRATEGIES -- TO TO BE ABLE
TO EASE THE TRANSITION INTO FULL
SEGMENTATION -- TO THAT END --
EDF BELIEVES THAT -- PROVIDING
INCENTIVES SO FUNDING FOR FOR
LOCAL MATCH DOLLARS --
SPECIFICALLY IN SOME OF THESE
AREAS WHERE THESE AND SOME
PROGRAMS CAN BE PILOTED -- IS IS
AN APPROPRIATE ROLE FOR THE
STATE TO PLAY AND AND AS A
RESULT -- ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND AS AN ORGANIZATION THAT'S
BEEN WORKING ON ON MANY OF THESE
ISSUES FOR FIRM YOU KNOW DECADES
AT THIS POINT -- WOULD BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO CONTINUE ENGAGE
WITH WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN
SOME SOME CONCRETE IDEAS AND
PROPOSALS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I'D LIKE
TO HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND IT'S
GOT REAL SCIENTISTS AND
CERTAINLY -- WE'D BE GLAD TO
HEAR FROM HIM THANK YOU
[inaudible]
EXPECT.
HI IRA -- HI I'M JIM HOLLY WITH
LAWRENCE BERKELEY NATIONAL
LABORATORY I JUST WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THE SUBSTANTIAL
CAPABILITIES OF CALIFORNIA'S.
NATIONAL LABORATORIES AS A
RESOURCE TO THE COMMITTEE AS YOU
THINK ABOUT -- THE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES YOU HAVE IN FRONT OF
YOU -- WE DO SIGNIFICANT WORK
AND HAVE CAPABILITIES ON ISSUES
SUCH AS DESALINIZATION AND THE
TREATMENT OF CONTAMINANTS SUCH
AS ARSENIC -- HEXAVALENT
CHROMIUM AT CETERA ALSO DO A LOT
OF WORK ON GROUNDWATER RECHARGE
SO -- IT'S NOT JUST LAWRENCE
BERKELEY NATIONAL LABORATORY BUT
OF OUR SISTER ORGANIZATION
LAWRENCE LIVERMORE IS ALSO VERY
INVOLVED TRY TO HELP.
OTHER IS A FEDERAL COMPETITION
RIGHT NOW FOR A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
IN RESEARCH FUNDING FOR WATER
TREATMENT WITH A FOCUS ON
DISSEMINATION ELLEN MENTIONED
THE HIGH COST OF THIS ALLEGATION.
SO BOTH LABORATORIES ARE ENGAGED
IN LEADING TEAMS TO TRY TO BRING.
US SOME OF THAT MONEY TO
CALIFORNIA I'D BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS OR ENGAGE
IN FURTHER DISCUSSIONS AT YOUR
CONVENIENCE THANK YOU.
WELL THANKS VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE AND SPENDING THE TIME TO
PREPARE YOUR TESTIMONY.
NOT REALLY APPRECIATE IT REALLY
WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO CONCRETE.
PROPOSALS AND THANKS VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK.
THE WEATHER TURNED.
WE CAN BE HELPFUL [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
OKAY.
DON'T SOMETHING.
SHOULD BE USED YEAH.
YEAH YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
THIS IS ALL ONLINE.
WELL ONE OF THE ONLY
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
I WAS [inaudible]
YOU KNOW [inaudible]
YEAH. ONE OF THE VERY MUCH AND
WE WILL DO ALL THAT STUFF